hello everybody
h3 podcast
in sickness or in health
uh
and forever
and been matrimony forever
uh
here we are
monday
i'm man i had a horrible weekend just
sick
still sick
like terrible throat pain i went to the
doctor yesterday
not coping though no i tested a lot i
tested a lot for covid
because that fir you
know you it's hard to believe that
there's other uh illnesses out there
right
but i i still kind of feel like i do
have kobe but i've taken a covet test
like 20 times also now you tell us
i i mean it's it i've take i i don't
know i can't prove to you no i know
anymore that i don't have covet no no
if you have symptoms and you've taken
like three or four tests and they're all
negative taken literally 20 times you
got the flu and a pcr test
oh that's nice you guys are real
troopers
today's episode's sponsored by
hellofresh
we love you
i was gonna miss today's episode but i
saw y'all losing your damn minds on the
subreddit and i thought
i gotta come save i gotta go come do the
show cause
everyone and people are just posting
dan looks like this person memes on the
subreddit
and it's just pure pandemonium
now i gotta admit that
i do think you look like this guy jk
simmons i've gotten it a decent amount
and i i guess i i see it a little bit
and i gotta say i also do think you look
like this better
i don't know who that is but uh
dude from viking valhalla bruh
and
this one less so i think it's just the
beard
that one looks a little bit more like
ian
right interesting interesting well i am
just the pokemon evolved version i am
actually i'm actually curious what the
[ __ ] this video is though because it's
eight hours one second long
find the answers eight hours sleeping
life changing eight hours of sleep
that's the last thing you need right now
yo
six hundred thousand views pull that up
what are they talking away studio wait
i'm curious what are they saying during
those eight hours in your ears
you know it like hour before whoa wave
stadium
you were listening to a long deep sleep
is that course
you know what like hour before he'll
slip and [ __ ] like
you will wire all of your money to the
bank account with routing number three
three two
like some weird
play it i wonder what he says highest
version of yourself
i designed this meditation to help you
relax fully
to get clarity and insight about who you
are skip to like hour four and then fall
into the deepest
most part
it's just like him like jerking off not
external measures
are you still awake
oh oh sorry about that
you can go back to sleep now don't worry
about it
i'm taking action today to avoid regrets
shut up dude
puts the lotion in the best get out of
my [ __ ] ear bro i'm trying to sleep
he must be using a harmonizer
i don't know
you can know what my greatest you can go
to
you know who he sounds like i haven't
been watching this season of the
bachelor really but i always hear aly
watching it and whenever the dude is
like sweet talking the girls he does
that exactly he's like
it's just so amazing to be on this
journey with you right now
you know what i think he sounds like
who's wait who's speaking oh
oh
hey guys
i think it sounds like cam
oh yeah oh you know what
i have to apologize to olivia who
is here
uh just in town right visiting yeah just
visiting you don't have to apologize
what for because we were going to go to
disneyland this weekend
and we had to reschedule
it's okay and now olivia is not going to
be able to come with us
next time i've been listening to olivia
the entire
yeah
cameron is that you cameron
okay fascinating well
dan apparently looks like now that
that's a stretch come on
kratos i don't the resemblance is
uncanny that one i can't give to what
this one i don't see at all actually
well i think it's starting to drift into
meme territory here okay this one
actually this what i this one i don't
really see to be honest there crews
you don't know something in the nose
maybe in the dome
okay
so people are just going crazy
arab dan though dude that's how bb that
one right there that actually does look
like yeah that one tripped me out
but this so i went on the subreddit last
night
and the first thing i saw was this post
was walking my dog and realized the
world looks like dan
and i and i was like what the [ __ ] is
this i didn't have any contacts
i said guys what is this
then i realized the joke and thought man
i better i better go to work tomorrow
these people are losing it
[Laughter]
is it me or chicago skyline look like
dan yeah
it does look like dan
i do see it
okay bro this dog looks like you
it actually does
i like that dog more than the other dog
which is later in the album you know
that that one gets posted like once a
week on the subreddit yeah that thug
looks like you bro
i don't know
i don't have demon eyes no a dog is so
cursed
that looks like you did i feel like i
feel really rude admitting it but that
does look like you downright enough yeah
come on maybe just minus the demon eyes
that's their dog's hair like that though
that's some wild [ __ ]
what did you give your dog a buzz cut
a fresh fade for your dog
oh god my head is like splitting right
now oh boy
that i'm not seeing
no anyone who's bald basically looks
like dan at this point i ain't your
daddy oh there's a lot of these the
alden ring one looks a lot like my elder
main character which
i made to look like myself yeah i
noticed i could just be a screenshot of
my character
this microwave looks like dan
interestingly
that
what the [ __ ] is that keemstar and oh 14
pages yeah that's them mixed
interesting
coming with that heat
avi's burrito that i see
the dude from uh attack on titan sure
commander pictures
uh okay i've seen enough there's a lot
of these
[Laughter]
i love that one ammo tip
wait is this the guy from like the mummy
yeah he's the bad guy from the moment
the guy who everyone thinks is billy
zane but it's not actually billy is that
not billy's aide no no there you go
billy zane wishes it was billy zane he
wished he had that work
i haven't seen that guy in a movie in
for ages
damn damn
and you guys are literally losing it
so that's what the subreddit's been up
to yeah
so it's good thing you came back
rescue us from this
uh
yeah so
it's been tough you know just been holed
up in the basement
lots of nyquil i'm on dayquil right now
whatever that [ __ ] does that's the good
[ __ ] you real you liked aqua good [ __ ]
dude
not doing much for me my head feels like
it's splitting open [ __ ] my ears feel
stuff so i can't hear so good
pee to my basement
i have been being in my basement yeah
rock and pooping all over the floor
i'm [ __ ] my pants dude what's this
thing
i'm [ __ ] my pants dude
so
there's [ __ ] all over the floor
um what's been going on how you guys
been doing eh
good unexpected little three-day weekend
this past weekend because of the uh show
cancellation and almost four
ethan really
it was like
2 45 ethan was like i don't know if i
can do the show today dude
i was like well
there's
20 000 people
waiting for the stream to start right
now so if you could pull it together
that would be good and he did he's here
a little late ethan but that's okay
well i showed up and then i passed that
on the couch immediately
i had to wake you up like a little like
a little kid hey honey hey sweetie
so um anyway
let's see here let's let's get to our
document we've got oh yeah this is i
gotta say
this is a good one i saw
this was this was on my for you page
so i gotta give it up when it happens
naturally
it's not going that fast it doesn't seem
like right
like it was not going that fast man
but somehow
somehow it delivers
that's awesome
like 10 miles per hour
[Music]
[Applause]
that's good [ __ ] bro
that's good
[ __ ] bro
[Laughter]
that's that way he landed man that that
[ __ ] sucks man
i feel like there's usually some kind of
a mechanism that keeps you from
catapulting off it right that they just
didn't
what the [ __ ]
that'd be sick if that's how every
zipline ended
well there you have it
still happening out there
the world is happening
jesse smollette the biggest dumbass of
all time probably
he what did he get he got like a lot of
he got like a long sentence wasn't it
how long
jesse smallette sentence yeah he
he came out guilty for faking the hate
crime
oh i'm sure you guys all remember that
it was huge news
i guess maybe i've ever seen 150 days
yeah not long 150 days
150 days in jail 30 months probation
juicy smoothie
his life was that guy never working
again
i'm pretty sure he got a fat bill from
the city too
oh yeah
but apparently he he's not happy with
the verdict eh
100 120 000
in restitution to the city
that's getting off light i feel like
yeah
well here let's see we'll see what old
joss
has to say
right now
he's like listen your honor it was a
real hate crime
i know you guys don't want to believe me
i mean you'll see what he says oh [ __ ]
does he really say oh yeah i'm not
suicidal
[Applause]
okay i'm not suicidal okay i am not
suicidal
nobody asks
nobody's gonna abstain you dude no one
gives a [ __ ] oh he thinks people are
getting oh
is that what that is i think so
bro you faked it like you're going to
jail for 30 days bro
that's awesome
i am not suicidal they're like okay
i bro innocent and i am not suicidal
if i did this then it means that i stuck
my fist in the fears of black americans
in this country for over 400 years and
the fears of the lgbtq community your
honor i respect you and i respect the
jury but i did not do this and i am not
suicidal and if anything happens to me
when i go in there
i did not do it to myself and you must
all know that
i respect you your honor i respect your
decision
jail time
i am not suicidal okay
mr ucha let me inquire are there any
post-sentencing motions i think that
guy's suicidal
i think he's going to try to hurt
himself for real though i don't know
because he would do that and he'd be
like yo they tried to take me out bro
hillary clinton came from me
they got to put him on suicide watch
does he care to present
hardester
i am not suicidal
yo can we sound like that
i mean i was watching this video and i
wasn't quite sure you know i mean it's a
little poor taste but it's also pretty
epic too i am not suicidal like it's a
rallying cry
i am not suicidal everybody
oh yo
i'll pull for the arsenal yeah you
better pull that that that's too
versatile
hey yo i'm gonna say that in the morning
when i arrive hey what's up everybody i
am not suicidal
like you said if somebody starts
screaming that i'm prompted like oh boy
yeah put him on to a flood watch
i am not suicidal
i am not suicidal and i am innocent i
could have said that i was guilty a long
time ago okay
bro they literally caught you in every
way imagine it's like the most slam dunk
case
like nobody's been more guilty there is
no
there is no wiggle room for you
to
claim innocence the guys who beat you
up who are black by the way
because the whole thing was that it was
a hate crime
we're like yeah he paid us some white
dudes and maga hats right yeah his
original yeah
they put a noose around his neck and
some white dude in maga hats yeah and it
was just two of his black bodies who
were like yeah no no we like paid in
like a check i believe
like
yeah in the memo he wrote for the fake
hate crime i don't know if it went that
far but you might as well have
yeah
he said henchmen in the memo it said
henchmen one and then the other guy
henchmen too so it was easy to trace
oh boy
yeah and they got the whole thing on
camera
of him faking it with his homies like
dude you're busted
but when you get caught that bad i think
i guess you gotta
just lie through you just got a lie
through the pain it wanted me
i caught you in the counter it wasn't me
it wasn't me
it wasn't me
was that a chris rock joke where it's
like no matter how bad you get caught
just say it wasn't me
yeah
possibly i don't know
i just know it from shaggy
should you bring it
well anyway um
shout out to jesse
shout out jesse who's on suicide watch
right now
he's not suicidal
right but he is
and obviously it's nothing to joke about
but on the other hand that's a great
sound bite
maybe
we should hold off on using that sound
bite until he serves his uh
six months until he gets out yeah alive
it might be no we don't have to wear it
it's jesse it's retroactive i mean it's
jesse smollett nobody cares about that
guy
come on
uh sound bites some sound by tick tocks
for me
okay so
this did we watch this guy before on the
show no i don't think on the show
okay so
this guy is a challenger you guys
know that i'm i love that dude who does
the uh yeah the cartoon sound
yeah yeah exactly so this guy's i don't
know who started doing it first that
would be interesting to know
by the way me and the other guy are
homies i'll tic tac now cause i followed
him and he dm me oh really yeah
i was like you're the [ __ ] greatest
comedy inspiration
you have transformed i'm like well i
gotta say
one not this one but one of the ones
that we have coming up has um
has turned me into a into a believer
okay i'll point out which one it's not
this one this one was still kind of okay
now i like this guy but i feel like the
other dudes the is the original
can you see who did it first baby can
you try to
yeah backtrack that look up the
genealogy of the feel like it predates
both of them but
i can check okay here we go
[Music]
yeah
that's actually talent i don't know how
the [ __ ] you move that muscle up there
bro
you like this guy more yeah i think so
it was pretty choreographed the eyebrows
i mean it just adds so much it's not
just the sound yeah
olivia talk to us how are you have you
been i'm good sorry i was it looks like
love is green screen doesn't it
oh oh he's here it may be
there was a uh
yeah we can't be in the same room
because we're the same i thought how are
you you went back to school or you were
uh how's school going i'm good i love
school i'm super happy
to be there for
my final sim but
i'm happier to be here
well you'll be back soon right yeah very
soon
does school suck or is it nice to be
back no i
i mean i love my friends i love
where i go so
i'm actually it's nice that's good good
time are you like a celeb back there are
people kind of
no
someone the other day did post on the
kenyan
oh my god i just said the name
someone just posted um
there's like a crushes page and it said
olivia h3h3 like that was my last name
wait there's a crushes page yeah
wait where did you anonymously submit
like crushes
this is like a website for your school
where people post crushes yeah it's an
instagram
it's an instagram page so how do you do
an instagram page and in it
there's like an anonymous forum link and
then people post there
and you you were browsing it or did you
hear there was a post there follow that
account i am on that account all the
time
i want to know the gossip on campus i
wonder if people are making connections
there
like if if that instagram has
been a matchmaker yeah
i would like to see it
you know
do you think it's a little like i mean
you guys are like in college like at
what point do you all just tell each
other that you like each other
that's boring
yeah right i mean i mean we gotta gamify
it this is it like a gamify once you're
out of college pop it off of it i'm just
saying once you're out of college you
stop meeting people this is like your
only chance yeah so unless you want to
die alone you better get off that
[ __ ] forum and approach her that's
depressing i have to find my husband
right now
well i'm talking to the guy or girl who
has a crush on you oh true i shouldn't
say who thinks my last name is h3h3
she's clearly done his research
obviously my name is olivia
h3h3 that's right it's legally well all
you guys are i make you all you change
your name we're we're now the pod squad
we're talking about this
that's [ __ ] up
don't invoke that the pop squad the pods
what oh boy we're like why don't we have
a cool name
how about i smash your face
then can we be the pod squad yeah okay
yeah
[Music]
enough crimes have been committed here
huh we got up those numbers yeah we
gotta give well maybe you'll get fatally
injured at the boxing match
i'll do it for you guys not my fault
though
yeah i don't know you guys have been
pretty rough with lovebot
doesn't that count that's true
or yeah robot lives matters that is
robots lives matter that's true i guess
this is
the pod squad
yeah
um well okay it's nice to have you here
olivia thank you very nice to be here
looking forward to having you back
permanently
me too
and uh unmasking that secret admirer
whoever it is email dan we'll see if we
can yeah
well we can set up
for real thanks
well someone's gotta get on it i mean we
gotta we have to work this out
yeah i wanna know who it is
is this page very active at your school
oh it's heavily active
what
is that a common nowadays and college
campuses to have a page like that like
yeah i think it's a common practice for
small schools probably interesting
what's wrong with these people just
says his campus had it
yeah you know
you'd listen i'm not the most attractive
man out there
but you gotta just shoot your shot bro
don't be a baby
you're gonna finish school you don't
have that much time on this earth
to be crushing on someone you don't even
know is interested in you that's true
just go up to them
say i think you're beautiful attractive
and whatever it is you like about them
i'd say i'd like to uh
get your numbers that pop is that okay
my seed is all over this place ew
wait what was that what the [ __ ] is that
banks those banks why is this seed all
over the place i don't know
where did you get that
magician never tells the secrets
you
gross
you know what i'm saying get off the
crush [ __ ]
talk to them see if they're interested
and move on
you're about to finish college right
olivia
right you're about to graduate yeah they
need to they need to come up to me they
need to ask me my real last name
right
do you know at that teddy fresh pop-up
how many people asked me about olivia
how many guys try to shoot their shot
seriously i swear to god do you
like they were like yeah i reached out
to olivia maybe you could put in a word
for him like dude i met you 10 seconds
ago oh my god wait
i love that
wow
so i guess i'll be there next time five
dollar donation yeah you're gonna set up
a booth dude yeah
we got donations coming in just to let
us know that they have a crush on olivia
oh my god keep that up i have a crush on
all of you too stay single oh don't
simply like that you're just trying to
get your donation for me yeah
come on guys keep them coming olivia
olivia i've been watching you the entire
time i've been listening to him so just
an update i think your guy was first for
the sounds
making this i knew it i knew it he's the
originator i mean as far back as i could
see he did in october
and the other guy started in december
interesting oh innovator yeah yeah yeah
now he's talented don't get me wrong
but there's something about the original
flavor
but let's get let's continue on let's
see
oh [ __ ] what is this
[Music]
by the way it's a little delayed when i
watch it
huh are you seeing that like it's not
synced up perfectly no i think it's
actually tick-tock
because it when you publish a video the
audio gets a bit delayed i'm not just
yeah
because it's
yeah that eye movement
i mean it loses charm when it's not
totally seen
so i think the professionals are
recording outside of the app and this
dude is recording in the app oh yeah i
think that's a difference you got to
take his game to the next level
people go bro what is my for you page
why are you talking this is
why i'm on tick tock
[Music]
w placement and timing
[Music]
okay
interesting
that one had three million likes so it
is popular popping
very interesting
could someone do me a favor take that
one cameron this is probably good for
you right now
download that one he's screening calls
right now actually oh okay someone here
download it and then sync it
okay and then i want to watch it
all right okay and we can see if it's
actually dope or not
i can't really tell and then maybe i'll
re-upload it to my
now that's
i'll re-upload it to my tick tock yeah
i'll be like fixed i see no issues or
not
i'll tag him
here's our boy deandre
it's like damn girl
i could control his face man he's got
he's got all kinds of muscles in his
face i don't have access still
see this one synced but the other one
wasn't
right they were saying the professionals
know to do it out of the app because
precision is the key got it he was he
was an amateur trying to step up to the
big leagues and he fell
fell down
top comment is i'm trying to start this
youtube but not sure where to start give
me some ideas would y'all
i love the um
dude it's so hard to transition from
making videos like this to
doing youtube videos what if you want to
go to youtube you're getting 3 million
likes on a nine second video right now
probably because you made like 30 cents
from it well yeah you know
buy a dick fair enough
let's check his page let's see how he's
bought if he's popping
1.2 million yeah he's popping dude he's
got good really good views
don't worry about it i actually do cuss
a little do you also what's your
favorite curse word probably [ __ ]
i actually do
okay
love that and then finally
here we go
oh is that dan
bro
yeah that guy looks just like you dan
maybe that's why this is the one that
really cracked me up oh this is the one
you like
[Music]
damn you guys all got elastic ass
lips and cheeks
i don't think i could do that
for my audio listeners
nope
there you have it now i'm wait now how's
that going
you got it i'm uploading it now okay
good oh you're working nice so
this segment is obviously culminating
and the
i think it's going to be good
yeah once it's seen because it was a
strong submission it just had some
technical issues holding it back so
let's take a look and see
we're going to mean time we've gotten
like 20 more donations uh
asking for olivia's number
yeah you can get 20 bucks yeah let me
read it out or olivia you want to just
read that out
no
oh wait wait we have a gary vee stan um
who wants to debate me this should be
interesting
hold on
we're still waiting on this
it's up oh what's up
let me watch this video first
the gary okay so this is
this is this video synced up and
let's see if it's a banger
[Music]
that one was kind of out of nowhere eh
this one
a little bit of spittle came out oh
that's powerful that's really powerful
[Music]
pretty good yeah
yeah i like that i'm very weak for the
fortnite song
[Music]
that eye movement could use a little
work yeah
a little quicker on the twitch
[Music]
okay
not bad now we fixed it yeah
thank you ab well done no problem all
right should i debate this garyvee guy
it's a little early in the show for
getting heated is it not i'm not gonna
get heated
right now we're actually at 32 minutes
it's too late ethan's on the phone ethan
hello ethan
i'm ethan i'm a fan i'm not trying to
get heated i'm not trying to get heated
just calling in for fun
okay well there's two ethan's here
hold on hold on so we gotta get this
working now we have to establish
which ethan is
who's talking ethan
okay so i'm ethan and you're ethan
um
[Music]
oh
i don't know
okay continue
you can call me beer that's that's uh my
last name maybe what's your last name
beer beer like the journey yeah okay all
right so what what do i do appropriate
i'm not sure what do i have wrong about
garyvee
i think you v-con and the v-friends
thing like you call it a scam all the
time it has no value it's just a drawing
i think it's more than that
all right
um when you buy a
a v friend you're buying yourself a
ticket to a conference with all these
celebrities the demilios liam payne
booga
people
uh a bunch of other people why would
those people go to gary's conference
because you're meeting a group of
like-minded entrepreneurs which is what
he does like dixie dimiglio she a
like-minded entrepreneur
um in my opinion no but if you think so
listen the value is in if you think it's
valuable you buy it if you don't you
don't i just think to say it's just a
doodle
it's just a little bit of uh come on
like that's where we're garyvee's
selling a doodle for five thousand
dollars yeah you're buying a conference
you get to meet him actually i didn't
know that
no i mean we had talked about how he was
trying to pitch it as uh he has that
restaurant i guess maybe that's
different
what is this info about the conference i
think i also i'm also here to defend the
restaurant if possible but
oh
but real quick with this
but with this conference
so
why
does it need to be an nft to get access
to this conference why not just sell
tickets like every other conference what
what what is that yeah
that's that's a fair question dan and i
think the cool thing is like the
metaverse which i i agree with you guys
it's a little scammy i i agree but one
of the cool parts about it is you can
like show off your your nfts and if if
guess what if you run into like another
garyvee fan and you show off
oh guess what i'm also a garyvee fan in
fact in 2019 i went to the conference
the v con exclusive conference at only
100 like it's a cool kind of braggy
thing and i guess it's harmful for the
environment i'm not the biggest fan of
nfts i'm just trying to say that do you
own a vp
i don't they're too expensive i wish
right
so if you buy it
so if you buy a v friend
you get access to this conference right
has this conference happened already or
not yet
no no i got postponed due to covet it's
happening i pulled it up just to look at
it now may 19th to the 22nd this year
and it it happens every year so you get
it you you buy a v friend and you get to
go to this conference every single year
with different celebrities and all this
and so meeting garyvee if that's a thing
for you how much details do you know
about this conference he has guaranteed
celebrities at his conference for you to
like
if you go to v friends on instagram
there is a post with all the people
committed to attending okay and then he
also has said that there's others that
are but do you think so what are you
going to do go shake hands with the
demilio sisters i mean what is that
like they'll speak they'll speak maybe
again i'm not the biggest fan of
emilio's i'm the biggest fan of logan
paul but like they'll speak they'll give
advice and it's also like going there
with those like the people that are
entrepreneurship-like or into crypto and
that that stuff and if you're into that
stuff and you're like mine did did i see
that
like yeah facebook doesn't mean no i
hope not oh no
oh
no wait so you can only attend a vidcon
if you own a v one of his nft correct
correct okay where it's like an entry
ticket type of thing minnesota
uh minnesota wait see the lineup
you should broadcast live i gotta buy
one of his [ __ ] you gotta turn love
and cam out there to live you gotta send
love and camp for life report but like
and anyone who's excited i'm confused
about this
to be honest because
if it's just people who own v friends
it's just going to be a bunch of rich
people and it's going to be not a lot of
people so why don't you leave out a lot
for
why the [ __ ] would one of these
celebrities want to come and like
give a speech to 100 people what so well
when they get minted they're not as
expensive as they resell for
so there's
some people who's lucky who's not like
crazy rich who got them fine how many v
friends are there though like he's not a
lot for free he gives that a lot for
free he does sorry yeah
yeah he gave out a bunch with with his
book sale like if you pre-ordered a book
there's a chance you got something like
that just like a wrap which i guess you
could
yeah i guess it's a raffle but i mean
you can see it as if you're a fan and
you you were gonna buy his book anyways
you have a chance of getting it i guess
i actually see
why a lot of these celebrities would
want to come speak at a conference like
this you have suckers you have a captive
audience huge
that's a fair way to look at it and you
guess
okay like that no i'm not i'm not here
to a hardcore wait hold on i got you no
i i i get where you're coming from wait
i actually have a hard time believing
all these people are coming i don't
[ __ ] believe that these people are
all they're friends with gary they've
they've all gone on his podcast people
truck but there's gonna be like hundred
people there's gonna be more celebrities
than people well all of these
celebrities are
are involved in well i don't know about
the demilios but like banks people like
a lot of these people are are crypto
people okay fine
are these are also friends with gary
[ __ ] yeah i saw that wait is this the
first v-con
this will be the first one okay this is
i'm gonna project this this is gonna be
a [ __ ] show uh-oh
this is gonna be a [ __ ] show i mean i
don't know how because it doesn't make
sense that all these celebrities are
going to be there and only people with v
friends can go because like the numbers
just don't make sense do you have to pay
to attend the conference
well you have to just have this you have
it included yeah if you buy the nft you
get it okay so you don't have to pay to
get in and he's not selling tickets to
the general public i guess you have to
pay for airfare or a hotel for three
nights well yeah and you gotta you gotta
pay for the nft itself i know he's
taking that money and using it as as
ticket price something is not making
sense
he's not charging i understand he's made
a [ __ ] load of money from selling the
nfts but there's no tickets to the
general public he's not charging people
to get in excluding the nfts he's having
like a bajillion celebrities there and
it's something is not making sense this
is gonna be a [ __ ] you're looking for
something to be wrong
well we'll find out we is going to be
easy to wait
i mean he's got
yeah i don't know i mean
despite him being cringe it seems like
he's got a big operation like i'm sure
the event itself will be produced he's
been talking a big game about all this
nft [ __ ] and the restaurant and
everything and it's about to come to
fruition and we're going to see
this may if he's full of [ __ ] or not
this just doesn't make a thing
it's really long i mean
it doesn't make sense
a lot a lot of people yeah
hmm [ __ ] hassan
he's not going to be there hassan minaj
i think he's not going to be there yes
he will he's underestimating his
his podcast reasons times yeah
how many v friends are there like uh ten
fps that people own ten thousand ten
thousand yeah and i'm sure he probably
has some sort of residuals on too so
even if you resell the ticket ten
thousand of that shits
i'm not sure if all ten thousand i mean
i didn't say access to the show but
when you guys are asking what's the
benefit instead of just selling regular
tickets i'm sure the residuals alone is
a huge benefit if he's doing that for
him yeah yeah
how is this list of attend this is still
going i've just been scrolling that's
what i'm saying i'm sorry but is this
like a multi-day event or what
uh yeah it's like it's from the 19th to
22nd so like three days you're getting
your money's worth or you can you can
argue that i'm not saying you 100
percent are so how much is it
listening to her for 50 minutes can we
get it can we get some defense to uh to
send a crew
oh you want to buy it if you have the
friend of gary's dad i don't know if
that's valuable did he draw one well by
the way i will admit that i didn't know
that the whole v friends thing was a
ticket to v con well that may have been
i didn't know that dimension
so that actually does add a bit of value
where i didn't see it it's the vcom will
be an nft originally airdropped to v
friends nft holders this spring you may
buy an nft ticket on a secondary market
such as openc after the nft tickets are
distributed to v friend holders stay
tuned for more updates so yeah i mean
that's that's the primary way to get in
it sounds like
i mean it sounds like that the concept
is interesting actually i'll admit
i just i i still why not just sell
tickets
because this because he makes more money
that's what it's online in a cool way he
makes more money but that's again
this is what i've been talking about
with this with all of these things it's
like
whenever
i try and understand like what the
improvement is or what the like
additional value uh value add to one of
these nft not just mts but all of these
like web 3
things it's always like well it's kind
of like this thing that already exists
but people in the middle are able to
make a bunch more money off of it
like that seems to be the primary
benefit most of the time is
i can make more money off of it by
monetizing this thing right but also
it's sort of his brand that if it
doesn't succeed then it doesn't but if
nfts do continue to be a thing he has
all this footage of people saying again
that oh this isn't going to work out or
this is stupid and he'd say oh i was
right all along
like he has in the past and gary v is
very
yeah
he's very open about the fact that 99 of
them are scams to be careful
well he's very open about that he's not
yeah i mean it's yeah but like you said
it's basic
basically he's
the thing is like
part of what this is and i think
part of what nfts are bad they're sold
like democratization or some kind of
interesting thing but all it's doing
let's say that v con becomes this big
thing that everyone wants to go to
is that it's centralizing money and
power to people who are already rich
and powerful and wealthy so now everyone
who owns you first of all okay sure some
people got lucky and bought a v friend
really cheap most people buying it now
are rich [ __ ] people who are spending
hundreds of thousand dollars on it
so now you have to
open the fact that there was there was a
conference from the beginning when they
were originally minted it's not like
it's
oh only if you want to buy a doodle
that's when it was cheap right i mean he
was open about the fact that there was a
conference i'm sure he was and yeah no i
get that i'm not saying now everyone who
owns a v friend is a gatekeeper
essentially to who gets to go to this
conference
and they can
yeah i know elitists and
but that's all but yeah you're planning
on printing uh printing more as well
right i mean there he is and i would
print free money if i could i'm sure
rich people will buy it
so
i found the mint price for a v france
and it's
uh 0.5 ethereum
so right now that would be 1.2 k
wait what does it mean a mint price so
the first price that garyvee sells it
for
that makes sense so it's how much uh
one thousand two hundred dollars okay
so it's a it's a ticket to a conference
for
one thousand two hundred dollars but if
you buy that forever for three days for
three days for this year wait so you
have to buy a new one next year
yeah oh this man is pretty money no you
don't want to buy a new one
every year you get
no i yeah it would make more sense if
it's like a life forever
yeah i think it is that's what makes it
valuable that's how the restaurant i
think it's been for a couple of years at
least right until he just thought i
could be wrong change is the name of the
conference junior no you had a you know
this is gary khan let's not talk about
making money
tai lopez is crying right now he's so
[ __ ] sad what do you think about tai
lopez's [ __ ] there ethan did you follow
up i agree no i agree he's a scammer
like i i think there's i mean that's
an interesting uh
that's an interesting thing i guess
we'll see that's going to i don't think
that'll go very far yeah i don't think
that's
poor thai lopez he got something but he
has a history of scamming people like
yeah yeah like a history of helping
people in my opinion and i think
i know this will be helpful okay you
know what let's see let's see i didn't
know that dimension it that certainly
does make it more interesting more
compelling more interesting than just a
stupid doodle yeah i agree sure it does
at least there's like something behind
it absolutely it does change it so
you're right ethan from new jersey
all right thank you and we'll see in may
actually
i'll be watching uh
with a lot of anticipation to see if
it's a [ __ ] show on may or if it goes
smoothly
all right maybe i'll be buying a uh v
friend here
maybe i'll maybe i'm going to be coming
in
maybe we're going to have a client next
year are you so tell me ethan do you
listen do you imagine killing uh your
family
every morning my entire family every
morning you do that i wake up i picture
a shotgun to their head nice yeah and is
that your secret one thing that brings
me happiness yeah is that your secret to
happiness okay good i live my happiest
life
that's my morning mantra keep it up
ethan
the key to happiness is right around the
corner all right take care buddy thanks
for calling you're right you changed my
mind thank you so much you changed my
mind
peace
peace and love
ethan
ethan
i mean he's got i didn't know that
somehow i didn't know that
yeah i mean i still
again
it's it's
the same as all these nfts that are
being used as
tickets to
either a club or or a restaurant or in
this case a conference an island
um
it
it
yeah it's more interesting it makes it
more interesting it makes it more
interesting than than it just being a
doodle but only by about two percent
well it has more value yeah but you
could just sell passes but i'm saying
they own a pass in perpetuity so it has
value but you could say
in the same way i mean
lifetime pass you sell that for twelve
hundred dollars
and you can resell it but it's the nft
layer doesn't really like but it's not
on the nf it's not on the blockchain
exactly i just think it'd be funny
people showing up with gary's doodles
like yeah i bought one i'm getting in
the car yo dude here's my doodle
yeah
my donated fifty dollars said i'm
spending fifty dollars to tell everyone
to go watch the line goes up the problem
with nfts yeah we've shouted that video
out on the show actually uh it is
good it is an excellent watch pretty
much he he pretty much shout out folding
ideas
completely dismantles the whole nft
crypto thing
i think that's the video that ultimately
made me not want to work with uh crypto
companies anymore
it does seem to be making
waves
i i mean what are the views up to
because i i've actually been a fan of
his for
several years now and i've never seen a
video of his uh hit like that um
i mean it has six and a half million
views yeah i mean it's a feature length
film essentially two hours yeah it's two
hours 18 minutes long yeah it's really
good he completely dismantles the whole
crypto thing
um
let's think hellofresh
let's do that with hellofresh you get
farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered
right to your door
skip the trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy
fun affordable and that's why it's
america's number one meal kit what is in
that burrito
we don't know but i bet it tasted great
abe
it was amazing i'll never forget it
every day i think about that burrito and
i'm so thankful i see that burrito in my
dreams i see it everywhere that burrito
kind of looks like me kind of looks like
dan looks like dan yeah
oh yeah look at that flat bread i got a
new one
whoa enchilada look at that
oh
good alright show that uh flautas that
one gets me excited
[Music]
right here bro those look fire look at
that
mmm
spicy
[Music]
hungry i haven't been eating much
because of my illness getting me all
worked up wait show pull up baby's
burrito
uh
ah perfection there you go now that's
food i'm proud of that
that's the best [ __ ] food pick ever
it may
and i don't want to you know overstep it
may be the most famous burrito
of all time
huh i mean there's it could be i mean
there's not a lot of competition there's
there's twitter fan pages has there been
really yeah maybe is it really yeah
oh [ __ ] and the thumbnail is right three
spelled out have there been any uh
prominent uh
celebrities
famous burrito david dobrik had a
burrito
oh just want to if anybody's like choked
to death on a burrito and it became like
an infamous but the image of that
specific burrito will not be as famous
as this burrito what about you you know
what i'm gonna make this kind of thing
fake paparazzi pics of justin bieber
eating the burrito wrong oh eating it
from the side no yeah but that was fake
right it was fake but it was famous that
it would again he's got a point she's
got a boy he looks like olivia yeah i
remember what the burrito looked like i
don't believe you i'm sorry i promise it
was big and he was eating it from the
middle
of my burrito or bieber's burrito okay i
will be honest with you your burrito
thank you olivia yeah
i think we have a ways to go but we're
working there
okay well we'll keep chipping away each
week hellofresh delivers pre-portioned
ingredients to your door including farm
fresh produce produce that arrives
within a week so you get
convenience without skimping on quality
skip the trip to the grocery store
save the weight in long lines and ensure
you don't waste money on excess food
hellofresh has fit and wholesome recipes
for satisfying and nutritious meals
that you can feel good about i cannot
read right now
you don't even have to think about it
dude
i need like reading glasses all of a
sudden
that you can feel good about
with six recipes per week to choose from
including low calories and carb
conscious options
here's how it works they send you the
card it tells you what to do it's got
the ingredients pre-portioned out it's
fresh it's delicious it's easy to make
every freaking time
what more do you want
cabbage go to hellofresh.com
h3tv16 and use the code h3 tv 16 for up
to 16 free meals and three free gifts
that is hellofresh.com
h3tv16 use the code h3d16
h3tv16
they'd be like you slurred it h3tv68
thank you
hello fresh america's number one meal
kit
thank you
ah
[Applause]
um
tiana wants help
brainstorming
was one of the people keemstar was
tweeting about
okay
let's hear her out malia
so malia hello you had a spout spat with
keemstar on twitter
i did a little bit yeah um
oh malia thank you sorry
what was i saying yeah so
i get that a lot it's
i it's an interesting name and it's not
spelled correctly either so
very little people pronounce it
correctly
all right malia what's the situation
so
um i don't know if you guys saw
whenever some girl
tweeted at keemstar about that whole
side by side he did a view a couple
weeks ago you and him she just tweeted
him saying like
hey that's mean or like hey that's cyber
bullying and then he tweeted a picture
of her making fun of her
so
all of his fans came after her and they
started like tweeting her like
really messed up like character
hold on let's pull it up because we were
going to talk about it let me catch the
audience up
with what you're talking about is this
in here maybe right right
excuse me yeah let's pull it up because
jesus christ oh here it is
uh
let's
see so keemstar tweeted out
okay [ __ ]
um keemstar tweeted out
this originally
uh 36 years old for seven days from 40.
the man is so insecure about his age
first
wait is this the one he edited of me
yes yes oh okay so we already talked
about this where he zombified me
and he's like look how old he looks bro
like i don't care about how
why is your life defined by how you look
compared to me
do you know what i mean
you're defining your life
by how you look compared to me
yeah
well anyway
like bro can't you just come get
just look in the mirror like
it's like he's got a picture of me next
to his mirror
like a romeo julia just look in the
mirror
compare yourself to yourself
they say comparison is the thief of joy
keemstar and you will never look better
than me you proved it
take your look at that [ __ ] airline
by the way which looks
really good today
okay there's a reason they call me the
hairline king dude yeah they do
okay
people have been remember keemstar
comparison is the thief
thief of joy
and if you're gonna compare yourself to
someone
at least due to someone who doesn't have
a god hairline like me you'll be a lot
happier in life now he's comparing me to
hitler i didn't say that but
now that you brought it up
you are hitler oh i'm saying it not even
a comparison just as straight up he is
so anyway brianna grace
quote tweeted and said this is cyber
bullying which is funny i disagree i
mean i think it's a funny tweet i don't
think he's cyberpulling me i think he's
just a pathetic loser but there's the
context so there you go uh uh
malia
malia so go ahead
yeah um so basically whenever he tweeted
that like the replies are just like
really [ __ ] up and like mean
so i just responded not really expecting
like anyone to see my tweet anyways
because people were going off but i
responded saying like
um
i said wow all the men in this thread
are so cool omg it is so sexy how they
bullied this girl for no reason ugh so
alpha
and
immediately after i tweeted that i like
looked down at my phone and i started
getting like all these responses and
stuff and like my tweet like people
started liking it and all this
but like
i don't
surprisingly i i mean to me at least
there was very little
to know like h3 fans or anyone on my
side over there he's blocked them so
every
what's that he's blocked all of them and
i'm not even making a joke he's like the
most block happy person ever well
i was waiting for that to happen to me
too
well not um expecting him to tweet me so
what did he tweet about you
so basically what was happening was
all his fans started going to my twitter
account and screenshotting my tweets and
my pictures and stuff
and my photo my
profile picture is a picture of me at
work and i am a stripper
so they started screenshoting my photos
and
tweeting at me or posting them in the
thread saying like who asked the [ __ ]
like nobody asked you blood [ __ ]
motherless
stuff
yeah so um i believe the context was
one of those guys tweeted at me calling
me just slut-shaming me basically for my
job and then keemstar responded to this
guy saying something to me about a
stripper and he tweeted at me yikes
just
just yikes got it uh where's the tweet
we don't get the we don't get the
um no no that's a different this isn't
it this is a difference
asked me for my twitter before but i
could send the screenshots too yeah
let's see the screenshot
but the anyway the reason you don't see
by the way i didn't give the context but
yeah he says
he posted a picture of this girl and
said no this is cyber bowling like look
at her dude
this girl is this girl is
check her out bro
yeah um anyway um the reason you don't
see h3 fans is because keemstar is the
one signaling you he's sending his uh
little insult army after you there's no
super troopers in that
so right yeah i'm not surprised so after
that they started um dming me and stuff
i just sent some pictures to a b on
instagram i don't know who to send them
to um but those are the some of the
screenshots of just the highlights
because there are a lot of responses but
then people started dming me and
responding to my tweets and i remember
there's one in specific where
and i blocked out all the names on all
the screenshots but there was one in
specific where i was complaining about
how it was a slow night at work
and the club i work at has like a
famously large house fee which means we
pay a lot to work so i was just
complaining about how like i wasn't
making any money that day because it was
winter time and not a lot of people are
going to the strip clubs and snow storms
and uh so this guy took a screenshot of
me complaining that it was a slow night
at work and that i was gonna have to pay
this big house fee and he goes
he posts that in the thread and he goes
don't worry [ __ ] or he says like not
even being a [ __ ] is going to help you
out
almost like
yeah
yeah he took a screenshot and said don't
worry not even being a [ __ ] is going to
help you out or some something don't
feel bad he doesn't have a mom so that's
why he lashes
that's the thing i actually don't take
it personally grateful yeah no not at
all i i felt like
pretty grateful that they were making
fun of me for something that like i love
my job i personally
i think it's fun it's a fun job
what's the most amount of money you made
in a day
um well i mean i live in a kind of a
small area i don't work in any i don't
work in a big city uh just a decent
little city in colorado but
i've made the most is about 1200. in a
day
yeah dude that's awesome pretty good no
i've heard i mean i've seen like
anywhere from like have you seen four
hours to 12 hour days 12 hours that's a
long day stripping
i've i've worked longer than that i've
worked 16-hour days you ever seen
stripper talk like there's a whole tick
tock for strippers where they show like
these massive wads of cash that they
bring home and some of them will like
wash them and stuff strippers
yeah there are some stripper tick-tock
accounts that i really like but some of
them are kind of like like they only
show that good side you know so a lot of
people don't realize like how hard it
actually is and like sometimes like a
lot of people don't realize that
strippers have to pay a house fee to
work i didn't know that for me every
shift you pay for every ship what
i pay the strip club yeah i paid the
strip club 160 dollars for every ship so
that i work whoa oh [ __ ] so wait what
yeah so if i don't know that's how it
works
yeah well do you prefer very do you
prefer it like that or do you prefer
where they take a cut
um
there's kind of
there's like a good and a bad to both so
like the last club i worked at there was
like a ten dollar house fee so it was
like nothing ten bucks took a percentage
out of all of our lap dances so like
every lap dance if i got like a 30 or a
50 dance they would take 20 out of it
and i would only get to keep 30. wow so
the good thing about this club is even
though the house fee is really high they
don't take any money out of our dances
and we get to be paying for whatever we
want for dances
what's that
shouldn't they be paying you
well we uh we just work off tips we're
self
we're independent contractors basically
yeah i had no idea that's all worked
that's really interesting
yes i mean we don't get any out we don't
get paid from the club at all the
closest thing we get is um
sometimes if your club has a bar like
the one i work at right now it doesn't
serve alcohol but the one i worked at
before did and
if a customer wanted to buy you a drink
it would be 15
and you would get a cut of that
so you get you get a commission off the
drinks they buy you
yes
interesting
incentive structure yeah that's weird
you get all trash to get paid to get
trashed do they want you drinking though
i think that you would want to stay
sober for that job
um
i i'm not gonna lie i drink every day
that i work
but
definitely you can't get drunk it is
a very dangerous job can i ask you a
question this might this is personal so
don't you don't have to answer it but is
there sex in the champagne room
um in some clubs yes um
i've never witnessed it i
the club i work at now has actually been
shut down in the past because there was
some prostitution going on
um
but i've never seen it i mean it's been
reopened so i'm guessing you know they
people don't want to do that anymore
because they don't want the club to shut
down but more often than not
that does not happen
um and a big part of that is because
strippers
at least me and a lot of my friends
let me let me start off by saying i
feel like prostitution should be legal
i'm pro-prostitution but
in the strip club whenever you do that
with customers if you like
give them blow jobs or let them finger
you or
god forbid have sex with them back there
that makes it much more likely for us
who don't do that to get assaulted um
interesting and it also makes it harder
for us to make money i see people are
doing good so it makes it a lot harder
you you want you want a very clear line
saying no touching right because i think
in la
there's like no touching at all like
it's illegal to touch
colorado the way it works is that if
your club serves alcohol then there's no
touching allowed and there is no full
nudity allowed but if the club does not
serve alcohol there is full nudity
allowed and there is touching allowed
there's a similar thing here when they
say touching what does that mean like
where can you touch so
basically uh they tell you you make your
own rules but there are some obvious
rules like there can be no like mouth to
genitalia there could be no
penises entering anyone or fingers
entering anyone
um but they basically tell you like i
know some of the girls so my rules are
basically
and i i had a hard time making money at
this club for a long time because i came
from a club that served alcohol and
there was no touching allowed so when i
started there all these girls like let
the customers do all this stuff i didn't
so i didn't make any money so i kind of
had to be a little bit lenient so
basically i let them like touch my hips
thighs and my butt and my boobs but i
tell them
they cannot
at strip clubs no wonder girlfriends get
so mad when their guys go to the strip
club because like when i grew up in la i
thought you weren't allowed to touch at
all ever but you're allowed to grab
ticks
on the club that's crazy i mean i am
very i'm considered very very
conservative for the things i allow
because i don't let them
know
that's crazy what's going down at this
time
a lot of girls let the guys like lick
their nipples and stuff like that holy
[ __ ] bro do they wipe those dips down
between lap dances
what's that do they wipe the nips down
between lap dances a little sanitation
wipe
rubbing alcohol i would hope so but i
honestly have no idea like i bet they
don't i mean
we always carry around baby wipes that's
one thing strippers always have and me
personally any time i get out of a lap
dance i always go into the bathroom and
wipe down like my ass and my thighs
um but i mean i've given life dances to
dudes who like just smelled so bad i
just had to go to the light i can
imagine
baby wipes
like
it's there's gotta be some real beasts
out there touching and breathing on you
that's gonna be hard oh my gosh yeah
it's
there's we have names for them some like
we call them like grunters or owners
grunters grunters yeah they're
guys who are like you'll be talking to
them out on the floor and they'll be
like super nice and polite and they seem
really cool and then you're like hey how
about we go get a couple dances and
they're like yeah for sure and then you
get back there once you start dancing on
them they start like
oh
in your ears
oh no what's the deal with masks
are people where what was the deal
during like the peak of kovid
so
i actually started working
september of 2020 so deep into covet i'd
say whenever it was whenever it first
got
you know huge in america but when i
first started working there
everyone had to wear masks customers and
dancers it [ __ ] sucked um
on like being on stage with a mask on
but
we all did it um unless you had a drink
so you know like basically restaurant
rules when you get into the restaurant
you have to wear a mask but if you have
food or a drink in front of you you can
take it off it's a nice loop so if you
are sitting at the table with a customer
having a drink then you could take your
mask off but if you're just talking to a
customer or you're on stage or you're
giving a private dance you have to have
you had to have your mask on and
unfortunately
um they abandoned that
pretty soon actually they abandoned it
long before the colorado mass mandate
was lifted
um but yeah nobody wears masks anymore
unfortunately i want to ask you another
question do dudes often jizz in their
pants because i've heard that happens
there and i've always been captivated by
it
so basically i have never known for sure
but if i'm dancing on a guy's lap and i
can like feel his like boner and he
starts like moaning and stuff or like i
just get a feeling it's gonna happen
soon i will like switch it up and i'll
like stand up and dance in front of him
or like stand over him so i'm not like
on his lap anymore because i don't want
that to happen right but it definitely
seems like it for sure does there have
been it's got to be i mean you're
grabbing ass
and all that that's crazy i mean these
places are wild dude
after i get done with the dance i always
tell them like okay i'll meet you out
there i have them leave first and i get
dressed and everything but there have
been a couple times where i'll be like
okay can you please leave so i can get
decent and then i'll make you out there
and they'll be like i need you to give
me a couple minutes
oh yeah they definitely
yeah yeah
that's happened to me a few times i
always just kind of assume that it's
like okay they don't want to go out
there with like a boner so you didn't
see like wet spots because yeah i assume
there's just a club full of dudes full
of their pants full of goo
nasty no i've never felt that but i mean
dudes will try to like whip their [ __ ]
out during the dance
you
you have to like jump up and just like
basically scream for security be like no
and they'll get thrown out so i have had
stuff like that happen or people will
try to like
people get really ballsy in the strip
club and they are they always get thrown
out but yeah that's like what's the
craziest thing someone tried to pull
the craziest thing i would say was
whenever i was dancing in florida
um
i was dancing at this club in northern
florida and i will say women like
straight
uh middle-aged women get crazy at the
strip club and i think they think it's
okay
because they're like oh i'm a girl too
like we're just girls being gals you
know
crazy
so what do they do really drunkly
there was this really drunk lady and
this was at a club that served alcohol
and we did this thing called roll call
where at the top of every hour all the
girls got on stage and we all danced for
like four songs and so i was dancing on
the side stage just like twerking on
like all fours and this lady comes up
and i feel like skin on me right and
like on my ass and i turn around and
this lady
like has pulled her kids out this like
55 year old woman has pulled her kids
out and she's rubbing her boobs on me on
my abs and i'm like oh my god
oh i tried girl's gone wow
yeah so i just like tried to like kind
of food away a little bit and luckily
this was only a topless club so we all
had our bottoms on um
but
i'm like twerking for this
do you ever like that wasn't it that was
okay okay
she grabbed my butt cheeks and like
straight up licked my crap
she licked your [ __ ]
i had a song on it was only a topless
club but she licked my crack holy [ __ ]
bro
so how did you react to that
i
i immediately like lurched forward and i
ran off the stage and i went to the
dressing room and i like wiped down with
like hand sanitizer can i ask you if
that was a guy they probably would have
gone to jail right
um
i mean it really was
it's up to you sometimes when people
don't
see stuff like that you know there's so
much going on and i had only been
dancing for about a month at the time so
i did it
yeah i should have said anything but i
was a little bit shy because i just
started dancing i was like a baby
stripper at the time
um but now i've i've definitely gotten
some people
thrown out
um
yeah you know it's funny keemstar
keemstar is at home crime right now
because
he insulted you and he's probably
[ __ ] in his pants right now
cream star
screaming
got him
wait so questions
i don't i really get the opportunity to
talk to a stripper so i'm getting all my
questions out now
do you ever um
do you ever get turned on from any of
the guys there or is it all just
work so for me
trying to think
i personally
i am in a very committed happy
relationship we were together for
just over a year when i started dancing
and we've been together almost three
years now not what i asked even
even then even if i
even if i was single i don't think i
could see myself
being attracted to a customer that's
good that's good that is interesting so
you know
a lot of guys there it's
you're selling the experience
and i just i can look at a guy and be
like whoa he's that's an attractive guy
but
him being at a strip club it's like
unconsciously makes me unattractive to
him
incredible
you're you're unattracted by default to
the people that are there
yeah so you in a way you do you have a
bit of a
love hate relation i mean you you're
do you hate the men that uh patron you
do you uh do you like are you disgusted
by them no
i wouldn't say i hate them or that i'm
disgusted by them i just
i it just it just feels like work to me
you know so like i have regulars um that
i like talk to on instagram i don't hang
out with anyone from the club though
yeah so i have like a work instagram
account that is my stripper name okay
and it's private so it's only i only add
people on there that are either like my
friends or men and women that i've met
at work
um so i'll text them and just be like
hey how's your day or if they ask me how
my day is i'll i'll reply i'll try to
reply that day just to like
keep the conversation open so that they
come like keep coming back and seeing me
and have you ever hooked up with a with
a client have you ever
have you ever had a relationship with a
client or never
um no i've been in the same relationship
since i started trying even
you don't think you could do it yeah i
don't think i could even if i was single
well this is very interesting there's a
lot i think i learned a lot today do you
guys have any questions about this
unique opportunity
no i mean i've learned a lot it's
interesting a lot of the girls in the
office and uh
maybe love a little bit want me to go
this weekend for my birthday
wait what we cut my birthday's this
weekend the girls were trying to do how
many years you have to go to the strip
club
what girls
sam olivia i never
no no no we we
want to take love for them for the ride
whoa you guys are crazy
apparently okay
isn't it is lena okay with that lina are
you okay with abe going to strip club
she is she responded yes with an
exclamation mark would you go with him
let me ask you this
would you be okay with him getting a lap
dance
see i'm gonna want to so hold on
would you be okay with him getting a
laptop he's okay i think so yeah she
said yes i would actually and would you
want to watch the lap dance or would you
give him privacy
i mean i know i could be there that's
cool
wow
i trust him i don't i don't want to
speak for lena but i think she with my
boyfriend i'm okay with him going to the
strip club because i know he's so
awkward i've taken him to the strip club
before
what's that i gotta bring my bongos with
me to this right back yeah bring your
bongos yeah
and you see this is like a possibly like
a bonding experience between you lena
and abe uh where you guys go get a via
lap dance
a lot of couples do that
i'm not feeling it
i will i will dedicate my birthday life
dance to love
now you guys better talk about the idea
before you go to the club
i ain't going you guys go why don't you
go with them love
love is not allowed yeah i'm not alone
you're 21 you can go love you're gonna
have the time of your life my innocent
ears i've never been to a strip club by
the way no
i mean obviously i go if they go but i
just feel really awkward in that
position well it's not it's not as crazy
here as it is where where uh
she works our caller works because you
can't touch right dan no touching
why are you asking me i don't know you
know i went with my cousin
in la i think it's the same rules that
she was describing where it's like
alcohol oh there's non-alcohol right i i
believe so i think it's it's not even
about touching i think if there's
alcohol that can't even be fully nude no
you can't take the body yeah right
that's usually what it is right i see it
yeah
i went the first time with my cousin tim
and that was the worst experience of my
[ __ ] life and it makes me never want
to go back what happened i want to know
where to begin like it's so i there's so
much that happened in like a half hour
to hours time that i wouldn't know where
to begin
how bad could it be you went through
that club
it was there a fight was there i wish
did he get did did you did he get
himself bounced
in his fan
he knew everyone by name he knew all his
schedules
he knew all the sketch so he's been
there a lot yes it sounds like oh he's
one of those yeah he when you said grunt
grunt i'm sorry what did you call it
runner grunter i laughed because he's a
grunter
[Music]
this one very sweet girl came up and
she's like hi tim tim's tim's out there
but he's always nice to girls
but he like pointed he never [ __ ]
point his life he goes don't you dare
[ __ ] talk to me i'm like what's going
on i'm like what did she do he's like
don't worry what do you mean you just
told the girl
don't [ __ ] talk to me he goes don't
worry about it
and she's like okay you're being like
that to him like what the [ __ ] is i'm
sorry about him she's like no it's okay
i know him i'm like i know him too
whatever is going on
can i tell you something
can i tell you something the last time a
customer talked to me like that he ended
up buying my underwear for a hundred
dollars the same night oh yeah cousin
tim would buy your underwear so is he is
he doing like some role-playing thing
with her
or is he genuinely no i think
i mean i guess my the dude i was talking
to was drunk and he was mad that like
girls weren't giving him enough
attention so he started because he
wasn't spending any money so if you're
if a girl sits down and talks with you
and you're not spending money or you
don't want to get a dance they're not
going to want to talk to you so he
wasn't spending money on anyone so he
got all mad that nobody would that ever
that the girls were on their phones is
what he said so when i went and talked
to him and he was like just get away
from me i don't want to dance or
whatever it is you're trying to give me
and i was like [ __ ] at a strip club
crying in the strip club probably a lot
more
yeah just staring
and then as i'm getting off stage he
like motions for me to come over and i
walk over there and he goes how much for
the for the underwear wow what a legend
what a transition
i don't know what's worse the second
girl that came up was like flirting with
him and he was flirting back and i think
that was even worse somehow she was
saying oh you look like shia labeouf
he's like yeah i know i'm like what who
are you looking at looks like shiloh
buffs so he has his little games with
all the girls there i don't know dude he
spends a lot of time there
and he knew all the codes and they let
you touch they let you do a lot more
than touch
yeah in detroit you could do whatever
you want
yeah free for all yeah i'm sure i'm sure
it's like that in la i'm sure there are
places like that in la2 all big city
well
you just got to know where to go
yeah i have a question uh for you oh
jack has a question
um first first time i went to a uh a
strip club it was a young man i was 18.
and the dancer we were sitting oh this
was a full new club probably yeah yeah
yeah so the dancer um
we were sitting in what they called
pervert row which was sitting along of
the uh
you know where the pole is
and yeah
yeah yeah yeah the uh the dancer put her
legs around
my shoulders and like
pushed my head into her crotch area now
is that a common thing
was it touching your face
yeah it was there man
well i can't and this was in la i'm
assuming somewhere around that area yeah
um yeah in the bigger cities that is
common especially in 18 and up full nude
clubs because they don't serve alcohol
so there's touching aloud um
but that is one of those things i
would
absolutely never do just because that is
like so dangerous there are so many
things that could happen to your
genitalia from like bacteria you know
right exactly do you think she liked you
is that why she did that i don't know i
i didn't ask for that in a place you
know it was your 18th birthday
it wasn't it wasn't all my 18th birthday
i was 18 but it was just a wait hold on
hold on hold on
i need some context here
you're at the strip club yeah just a
random day not celebrating anything no
it was one of those nights where i was
out with my buddy and it was like 2 a.m
and we're like okay sure
let's go to the strip club yeah
uh the bars are closing all the hangout
spots and then there's no alcohol
i don't recall
it was in la yeah well you were 18 so
whatever you want right yeah
you're sitting at the stage
yeah are you are you spending money yeah
we went to the atm and got 50s and
singles
okay
making it rain huh yeah
and then she and then she just came up
to you and blasted your face
dancing she was on the stage and you
know they you know do their dance and
what have you and you were making it
rain for her yeah and she put her legs
around my shoulders and just thrust me
into her crotch and um
did you enjoy the experience
that not so much exactly type of dude
you leave the strip club be like man
those girls were feeling me tonight yeah
that's what i was trying to get into
she really wanted me i really didn't do
that move
but not a lot of girls straight up shove
it on your face it was like right with
their vagina it was right in there man i
mean i was and as a home run and was it
did it shock you kind of how it happened
yeah i was shocked
and did she leave a snail trail
what is she
wow
[Laughter]
oh
how did the rest of the night go
i
i didn't know how i felt i don't know i
didn't i didn't really end know what to
expect i thought we were just gonna
watch i didn't expect any
fizzy play yeah and did you um
did you cream in your pants that night
zach no i did not cream in my pants that
night
just just just saying just saying
there's so much to learn from uh this
so a b it's your birthday how old are
you gonna be
30
30 30 30.
that's right welcome to the club baby
so when are you turning 30
saturday
okay
thank you
oh that's all i wanted so you guys are
saving though and so the girls are the
ones trying to get you to a strip club
yeah i don't know it seems like a little
bit of a set up i don't know if i'm yeah
sam and and olivia you this was your
idea why do you i mean
the idea was very casually
i was pushing to like to celebrate a b
and then the girls just came up with a
strip sam sam really wants to go
are we allowed to be having sam like
this sam
speak up
this is your idea when you don't know i
just thought it would be fun i don't
know
okay sam's just listening now
i believe this is the second time that
they have tried to get all of us to go
to a strip club that's what i was
thinking yeah yeah i said because when
we uh went to um zach's concert uh at
the end of the night
there was there was a place
for girls right yeah you guys are wild
bro
just be fair and for the record i'm
going to sit this one out honestly you
girls are wild and fun by the way and
fun
not to be detrimental you guys are you
guys are a good time apparently
yeah
so you're not gonna you're not going
uh i don't think so the last time i went
to the strip club my friend got whipped
the girl took off his belt with his ass
on stage
and i waited is this cousin tim or a
different one experience ever in the
strip club is that cousin tim or no no
no it was my other friend maybe drama
let's go get couples massages come on we
don't need strip club zach's older than
i am yeah
keep a nice low-key
keep it nice low-key lina gave you the
she's she's right there with you i mean
that seems pretty like a good time
like you said i don't know me when me
and lina meant we worked at a restaurant
where there's a lot of other girls who i
was close with before i even met lina so
i feel like she's more comfortable than
most couples but we've never been in a
situation what do you mean close with
i mean like i had a lot of girlfriends
at that restaurant like that what do you
mean girlfriends like friends there were
girls that would come hang out
and uh
you know lena couldn't stay out late and
stuff and i don't know we have a lot of
trust because of that but i don't know
how she'll be in this situation very
secure yes she's a grown
woman
lina's she rides man she writes she
writes for you bro ride or die yeah she
really is
well what do you want to do for your
birthday see some titties
make up your mind
i'm kidding you want to grab them at
titties because apparently that goes on
there i don't know i don't i don't know
let's just go to a nice room i just want
to hang out with my with my peeps but
the thing is dan has something a very
important prior engagement so i don't
know we got to work around that dan's
going to see some titties
i am i'm going to a bachelor party this
weekend for an old friend of mine i
don't think that we're going are you
going to script i don't think so
ironically
i'm going to the bachelor club or the
bachelor party and i'm the only one not
going to us apparently
wow
wow wow wow well if you guys are ever in
the colorado yeah we'll come stop by
we'll stop by that'd be
great oh yeah we'll make it rain there
and i'll guarantee at least one of us
not me is going to be [ __ ] in our
pants
i don't know man zach
you seem to be fair and worried about it
honesty ethan i have never
pre-ejaculated in my life okay
bro you're walking lots of information
there walking pre-co good job
yeah you are you're you keep calling me
out i think love is worried he's going
to jizz in his pants oh love for sure is
going to feed that [ __ ] he's a young man
love's got some build up love is a young
man he's scared to walk in there yeah
he's gonna get kicked out faster
love come back here i think love's
afraid oh she's out that might be a good
place for love to find his new bride
though i'm sure oh
not according to what you've told us
well
i want to do something family-friendly
go to a restaurant you know get get a
nice steak maybe
i'll i'll buy a bee on ice steak i
appreciate that but it's my birthday i
want to see your ass wait on stage
what
um what are the strip clubs like in
sweden if you have any idea love
i think they wear clothes there they
don't even get naked
they're fully dressed oh and and pant
suits
the stroke clubs in sweden i've never
been to a strip club
i remember there was a strip club that
opened in my city but everyone got
pissed
it was so close to a school so they was
forced to shut down
it was so close
you want to learn or you want to [ __ ]
you want to learn or you want to see
something the strip club that i'm about
to start working at is also next to the
school but the guy who owns the strip
club also owns the school
so it's like it's like uh an online
school like a big online school oh so
he's like a scammer you know he owns
yeah that explains why a strip club
owner would want to own a school that's
a red flag right there
all right well we've exhausted this
topic um
malia i thank you for calling and
sharing your story with us
i'm sorry that keemstar uh harassed you
online but let's be honest you're
crushing it you're making you're
probably making more money than he is at
this point 1500 bucks a day or whatever
yeah stay blessed
god bless man i definitely don't spend
all my time in my basement so oh that's
gotta mean something murderer
she's not a murderer
have you killed
all right he's talking [ __ ] now he's
going crazy you take care
keep going be good and uh and uh god
bless okay thank you for calling thank
you guys so much all right take care
a lot to unpack there yeah the chat was
apparently saying that call healed me
yeah
very informative
yeah
well there's just a lot to learn
those are good questions though i feel
like it's questions a lot of guys are
curious about yeah i got to you
know i got to ask it all as you know
uh so okay no strip club this weekend so
what do you what are you planning
i don't have anything right now elden
ring
30th you got to do something fun
i don't know bro come on you gotta come
out with us
my mom's coming to town on sunday oh
your mom yeah
but you guys were talking about going to
maybe she wants to go to the strip club
you guys go to bed
i want to go to vegas actually to be
honest that's what i'm going to do oh
you guys can take love that would be
great but i mean i want to leave you
though dan i know i was going to say it
kind of sucks because i would like to go
too but i want to go to vegas too all
right saturday let's go
i gotta just go to vegas in the middle
of the weekend
that's [ __ ] we're never going to show
back up we're going to be yeah well and
there's i need you to keep us on the
rails yeah i mean
i'm ready to make it rain out there i
haven't been to that that's what i'm
saying if if ethan's going i kind of
want kind of yeah you got a bender dude
i haven't been the biggest since i've
been like rich you know that's not true
you went uh like a year or two ago you
ran okay it was just me either we
weren't having fun
but like boys on vegas hell yeah hell
yeah he's been broke go to vegas
hmm any other [ __ ]
[Music]
we had fun but it's different fun
i'm not talking about strip clubs i'm
talking about i know but people don't
know you guys better than your own what
people think i was talking about i'm not
talking about playing poker yeah you're
talking about gambling
drinking
what's wrong with that what i said that
that all sounds great what's wrong with
all that no i think a b was like people
even think you're having sex with
prostitutes no no it's not right man
that's not right man
you kind of
jumped over what i was saying no i just
mean like they're going to take what
you're saying out of context like oh you
didn't say he doesn't have phone with
you uh he wants to do stupid [ __ ] you
know they'd be saying stupid [ __ ] you
know somebody has stopped man what the
[ __ ] is that [ __ ] yeah
since he use the mask
that's pretty good
no it's just a different vibe when you
go with the boys you know what i mean
have some wholesome fun
nice wholesome fun like
eli doesn't like playing poker
you know
doesn't do cocaine right
she did molly why is he
okay
no i can't do any of those drugs dan
don't [ __ ] me up for life
no but she doesn't like to gamble she
doesn't really like to drink i mean to
be fair i don't either but with the boys
you can turn up you know
i'm just going to walk around with ones
i'd be like to make it rain baby
i'm rich
follow you around with a boom i'll just
be like hold up let me call my sugar
daddy
you could be my sugar for the week well
what would what would you want to do in
vegas oh i don't know i'm just
have fun with the boys
i think it'd be cool to you know play
cards with you guys yeah just drink and
play poker that's honestly all i want to
do yeah maybe see a show get some nice
food yeah yeah it sounds very nice yeah
it's it's fun i mean i love being there
i'm trying to go to vegas you can smoke
indoors which is crazy what olivia
you want come with oh absolutely awesome
you would come this saturday
oh this saturday i go back to school on
sunday
perfect you just change your life
and come back
yeah i'll go from vegas yeah yeah that'd
be sick dude that'd be fun
that would be fun
i'm done
are you planning on driving
or flying
drive
see i can drive but i don't i'll see why
but i have four from la to vegas are
super [ __ ] cheap yeah and it's like i
hate flying though i like the drive to
be honest yeah it's a good drive it's a
nice try
it's pretty annoying dan's right
five hours
way back on a sunday is definitely
annoying
that is every time i've driven back on a
scene yeah that drives pain it sucks
yeah it does
i mean the flight is good i like flying
but it's like a thousand bucks if you do
the no there's like shuttles you can go
to vegas for like 40 bucks
40 dollars maybe it's probably not that
cheap but it's very cheap
which are you gonna go on the airport
you gotta do i mean it's gonna take you
like three hours right it doesn't save
you that much time i hate dealing with
all that i rather just yeah i've mainly
have some great combos forget about it
really what are you guys talking about
we talk about the drive
wow that cactus looks really nice
but i'm saying if i take the round round
trip
uh
frontier air doesn't anybody know
frontier air yeah
like they touched that like it has like
a big warning like you may die
those are the planes where there's gonna
see duct tape on the wing okay well it
is 57 round trip 57
round three bro i don't know
this is what i'm saying there's like
these shuttle flights wait they're like
wait for the low flares stop stop i
think they get subsidized by the hotels
because they want people stop the vegas
you're telling me gas prices are like
seven dollars and they're charging fifty
seven dollars for a round trip i think
that they get subsidized by the vegas
hotels because they that actually makes
sense yeah they want people to it's the
same reason why they give away rooms in
vegas so readily because they make their
money off the [ __ ] but i'm saying if
we take the baby seats out there i have
four extra seeds in the rolls royce if
you guys want to roll in that bath i
mean that's a way to get some respect
roll into town
yeah also you can fly private pretty
cheap there's something called like net
jet that's what i do but it's a thousand
bucks oh it is okay but it's really nice
there's no security or anything it's
crazy you could literally bomb that
[ __ ] airplane excuse me you could you
could hijack that thing and drive it
right into the lux
and are you like on it by yourself or
you wouldn't no no no there's there's
like 10 other people you know don't me i
got a new button by the way
you did that that comment was probably
is a good that would have been a good
first use of it yeah i've created this
button
that
in a single stroke cuts your mic and
plays this
jesus christ ethan calm down that's
crazy to say wait to like
okay you want to do this show or you
want to play with your [ __ ] butt
wait till i say something offensive okay
so it'd be like you could get on the
plane and hot literally
jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
can't be part of this conversation
not with my name already stopped
so wait if i have four seeds um
then
how many people are going will you take
my car in your car and i have five seats
and then you have how do you have more
seats than me
and have like a monster no you have four
seats with the car seats no i take the
car seats out two one there's three in
the back one in the front
oh how does a mustang have no i have a
challenger but i have four seats i'm
sorry i was counting my own seat
right okay
so then who would drive with because we
have well yeah we would need
[Music]
yeah we could all fit in our both of our
cars though yeah
let me talk to you let me take steeler
right huh hell yeah dude i'm gonna be so
sad wait yeah what are we gonna do
because dan well it's not my birthday
it's it's okay i don't know i can attend
no i i am totally zach's out yeah why
zach's gonna be sick that day i already
know that wait he already said he's not
i don't know i have so i have something
on grown toenail that day
i wouldn't go with if you guys can't go
let's just push it to next weekend
yeah so well you want to have a belated
birthday trip yeah oh my god we do it
next week
does that work
uh
i mean if you do it another week yeah
i'm i'm just not available that weekend
i'm just afraid without dan we might not
make it back alive
wait what is this demi lovato
somebody who just sent this or who found
this about to put the airline on
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh on 9 11 ever
i guess so i did not know that it was so
she literally tweeted that on 9 11.
dude this woman is a walking faux pas or
this like maybe she was a woman then is
that a pokemon or something
just say that they're a walking
uh
about to put this airline on blast 911
dude
that's awesome oh my god
dude that's i'm seeing that it's a
different date but she did actually say
this but oh somebody probably added this
yeah someone edited
it was in november
so let me see um do you want to go
to vegas
this or should we go next week in olivia
can't come all right well what are we
doing disney though because then we have
to also think about that
you could say i don't give a [ __ ] no
let's not let's not let's not
i'm only here three more weekends i'll
put it in the chat yeah tell me
because that's what i'm saying it's
coming up here
okay
so so we don't have many saturdays
basically we have
you know well you yeah
let's talk after the show
definitely want to go to vegas though
this boy is in i'll finally get some
respect when you roll up in a
rolls-royce yeah oh yeah pod squad trip
to vegas baby
spitting
i i have a fantasy of spitting in the
ballet's face when he opens the door for
me wow
thank you for your class warfare thank
you mr klein that's my tip peasant
pathetic spit in my mouth kiss my boot
if you want a tip that's terrible
then i give him a hundred bucks though
when he's when he kisses my boot all
worth it because i'm a i'm a benevolent
king
yo we have literally gotten
like an inch through the stalk
yeah no
well that call ended up
going places and we didn't expect that
was like
we talked for like 45 minutes maybe
longer
i've been eyeing down these that's the
point of this h3 tv though baby i wanted
to talk about this is loose
okay we got the mr beast bars oh yeah
not sponsored no affiliation just
because we wanted to try it right this
box remind me of like uh
like those selling sprees when they're
trying to like raise money for the kids
girl scout yeah that's what
their beast is doing for his own bank
account
because he's not going to like charity
or anything i know he does that a lot oh
hell no no no no no okay
he's getting paid he's got to give away
a [ __ ] chocolate factory though right
yeah
that's kind of a big deal
but it's just like those in school
they'd be like if you sell a hundred
thousand dollars worth of chocolate
you'll win a ps5 and then the richest
kid
whose parent works in an office building
brings in puts it in the break room
and they immediately buy like 10 000
bars and they win all the prizes i'm not
bitter exactly it was the same kids
germany yeah i remember i was better
because
yo [ __ ]
i tried i cared we all cared so much
about selling chocolate bars you know
thinking back on that that was just
[ __ ] child slavery bro that was
unpaid labor we were working
for the promise of like a pizza party
candy pizza party which i wanted
and room 108 won it because of [ __ ]
jeremy [ __ ] jeremy you [ __ ] where's
jeremy now
[ __ ] dead in a gutter we can have a
pizza party anytime we want
let's try this [ __ ] anyway my school is
magazines quinoa crunch chocolate so
what's the deal what what makes this
candy bar special
uh well we'll have to taste it to find
out i don't i mean i think it's just
normal ass choc i mean this one's almond
chocolate wait there's a ticket of mine
[Music]
do they all have that you've won redeem
at feastable. wait what what yeah it
says i want something
actually
i mean it's not a golden ticket but i
want something oh mine doesn't have one
i was gonna say they all i think there's
lots of prizes probably one one per box
or something it's probably like david's
puzzle thing wait somebody win well
that's what i'm gonna say
you redeem it
all right
you redeem it
i'll say i want something you guys
dude if you want to [ __ ] yeah
dan get to keep it now since he's
redeeming it yeah depends what it is
okay well let's find out this is
exciting
yeah this is definitely like dave's uh
and i forgot about david dobrik's puzzle
[ __ ] there's been people on like
youtube and stuff that has been opening
a bunch of these and wait i'm gonna put
in the code so don't show the screen for
a second
we go
drum roll
we won
what did we win
you can show now all right
ethan
congratulations my friend you didn't win
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] loser and how did you do that
take it from me
you just got silly zonka
congratulations you want a [ __ ]
factory full of rotten fruit with fruit
flies and worms and you see that
chocolate fountain that's not chocolate
that's my [ __ ] somebody swearing
[Music]
you just got [ __ ] silly songs
oh i thought this chocolate bar was
already open i was like this
[ __ ]
yo but what's that that's real though
the ticket you guys got
we made it very elaborate we went
through a lot of effort for this um this
is a fake ticket uh sam even put gold
[ __ ] fringing on it to make it look
super efficient cold fringing i actually
got to check it out you guys you got
silly zombies
on my dog yeah this website wait how did
you know i was going to open that one
uh we figured you were going to have
multiple sleight of hand ethan
dude you zomked my ass you got [ __ ]
donk bro
wait hold on i gotta open all these now
that that was the only one because i
mean like we're not going to eat these
are we
well i mean i'm trying a little bit wait
you can tell if there's a chocolate in
it
or
do you think dude wait hold on do they
really only sell these by the box
i don't know sam sam bought it
did you sell it individually
wait i don't think they actually give
you a ticket i think it's on the back
little peel-off thing
[Music]
wait now i just want to feel everything
oh the real way to cam says the real way
you can tell if you win is there's just
a qr code on the back so it is like
david it is david's [ __ ]
and people check it out i want to draw
attention to this too look at this so
you kind of threw it off a little bit
because you had me do it we were hoping
you would go but it says on the ticket
go to feastable
feastable.me
which is this website here that uh love
created
a loving recreation
yeah i built that [ __ ]
you just got zonka dog wait
feastable.news our domain yeah
we're gonna get food
you didn't have to build all this [ __ ]
we didn't have to do any of this but we
decided
i'm on your hand
i got to put you guys to work well we
were supposed to do it on friday with
ela here oh that's so cool and you
canceled the episode we had it all ready
we're making a joint that joint
joke that you zilli zonk does
yo that that was very funny
good we were like
a little worried we were like there's
like a 10 15 chance ethan actually gets
really annoyed that we did this
why would i get annoyed not me because
if you actually got hyped that you won
oh well who why would i what the [ __ ] do
i care
it worked out maybe i'll get another
rolls you got zonk dude
you got [ __ ] zonk and prepare for
that to become a recurring thing you're
gonna get [ __ ] zonked you guys will
never stonk me again you hear that
never stop
you guys say that you're gonna embarrass
yourself i will never be so i'm
unzonkable from here out silly works and
you're
warming the website right now
yo you guys see if you redeem the code
yeah go redeem the code yes
zach did that
in one take
with
dude that was so [ __ ] sick
so you can zonk your friends with this
website you can [ __ ] your friends you
put in any oh i forgot about the last
little easter egg the the code that's on
the ticket it says in uh leet speak cam
grants and uh
it backwards well i should have seen
that should have seen that coming see
all the hints over there backwards it
was all there
[Applause]
yo yeah you guys can go to
dot me and and um
and redeem your code your song
dude it does not work on mobile very
well i just want to put that out there
have your friends get songs on a pc yeah
right so how much is it for one of these
bars sam
i'm not sure they come in
like packs of each variety like you can
buy a box of each one or you can get the
value pack which is what i got
okay well
i tried the quinoa crunch i don't like
it it's too sweet as a european this
chocolate is like
eating dirt for me
it's bad it's really sweet i don't want
to sound bad but it's not good at all no
american chocolate is
i mean
you're not the first european i've heard
yeah [ __ ] on american chocolate
so this one's not good
i had the almond one it was it's i mean
it just tastes like a hershey's bar
which wait isn't great
we just wanna
[Music]
i don't know what's the selling point it
says four ingredients it's like maybe
add more
it doesn't taste good up that up that
and buy a few it's so sweet
it's just like overwhelmingly sweet
i find that they put a lot of sugar in
when the flavor needs like over
compensating
yeah it's probably just cheap choc like
the actual chocolate that's why they put
so much sugar in it yeah and then
there's another one almond
let's try this
with peace and love
yeah so people are apparently buying a
shitload of this just like in willy
wonka just to redeem it and not eat the
chocolate
yeah
i mean you win a [ __ ] chocolate
factory it's a it's a big deal
[Music]
it all tastes the same i mean the
flavors are all the same
because there's like almonds in this one
and quinoa and this one but the effect
it has is so negligible it's just very
sweet
chocolate yeah
i couldn't fathom eating this whole bar
and i'm a [ __ ] fat piece of [ __ ]
i couldn't eat that whole bar so you
want to know why it tastes so bad
why is that there's another layer to
this prank
you [ __ ] it you're eating zach's
[ __ ] right now
you got zonket again dude
and that's pretty good [ __ ] a bar of
[ __ ] if if this is [ __ ] then i would say
it's actually pretty good shout out to
the chatter who just said that
was that's a good idea so wait the first
ingredient is cane sugar is that normal
for chocolate probably first ingredient
what do i know about chocolate
production
oh no [ __ ]
it's the same in my swedish chocolate
first ingredient sugar marabou
what's the second ingredient um
cake cocoa butter
this one says
chocolate liqueur
the frick
what
this is horrible
i mean it's literally it's the worst
it's the bottom tier of chocolate
it's clearly being mass produced in like
uh
count chocula's [ __ ] factory who
makes like
dog [ __ ] bars for whoever
just saying
i don't know what's his angle there
except that you could win prizes
in my opinion if you're gonna make a
product make it great
[Music]
i mean it's a [ __ ] gimmick right he's
trying to do [ __ ] willy wonka meme
the chocolate but the name the chocolate
is secondary i love the feastables name
like it's got legs
i feel like it could be something
[Music]
you know
but there you have it
so i'm gonna need you guys to check all
the codes okay to see if we want
we have about like two am i gonna be
sued over this website should i take it
down
well let's wait to get the cease and
desist sure okay that makes sense
well i think it's pretty obviously
parody right like if i don't think mr
beast is going to sue me first no i
don't think so you know
but i think when you try to redeem your
coupon it becomes apparent
that it's a parody website sure right
zonked
[Music]
great performance zack thank you you
brought the heat very impressive thank
you wow
[Music]
what else do we need to talk about tom
brady who cares
tom brady is out of retirement wow next
i just thought it was funny that he made
a huge [ __ ] deal and it was like this
whole media storm about how he's
retiring from football there's
memorials to his career the greatest
quarterback of all time and literally
like 30 days later the dude's like uh
you know what
never mind sounds like keemstar yeah he
pulled the team you're right
supposedly someone was uh won a bid on
his final
game ball for like over half a million
dollars
i guess he didn't pay for it yo that's a
bad purchase
well you know that reminds me of mark
maguire
back he broke the home run record
legend and somebody
bought his ball for a million dollars
the
home the break
yeah the record breaking and then the
next year
someone else beat his record because
everyone was on steroids then right yeah
i was going to say weren't all those
like yeah they all got they all got i
think it was barry bonds yeah someone
like that but he in like the record he's
got like an asterisk next to his name
damn yeah because they were all juicing
yeah
juiced up boy
yeah just some random [ __ ] dude mark
maguire he was like a nobody he was like
a decent player and then all of a sudden
one season this guy was cracking nuts he
broke like the like 50 year standing
record for
home runs in a season
i remember i'm suddenly the greatest
batter of all time i think mcguire was
juicing too
he was yeah yeah he he lost his [ __ ]
he's he's a juicer
just let them choose [ __ ] it
juicing just juice up do you think
athletes should be allowed to use
steroids
it's like any
thing with drugs it's like
they've been trying to ban it for years
and they all do it so
it's a joke
or some [ __ ] i don't know it's kind of
dangerous though too because then it's
like you s you set this
basically you have to juice if you make
it legal because right you'll never keep
it true
and not everybody can't should be doing
that not safe
all right just keep doing it illegally
then [ __ ] it
baby i mean yeah the lance armstrong
thing was shocking shocking that [ __ ]
guy was using steroids the whole time
yeah for everybody rocking those
bracelets
live strong baby
i'll tell you what with steroids you
will be living strong that's right he
zonked us he's honked the world he
zonked the world because you know my dad
owned a bike shop
growing up that was his job and so
he was super into the lance armstrong
hype and the whole
so when it came out that guy was juicing
man that that really was
world chat gary was devastated
well yeah it's like this this man was
was a hero sure
those bracelets were so [ __ ] popular
i mean it was crazy i yeah i want my
money back
his thing was like everybody was using
steroids
right exactly but i don't know if that i
mean the same with mark mcguire
when
when he
won uh or when he broke that record
as well as barry bonds
pretty much the whole league was doing
it so
he was still the best one on steroids
that's gonna be worth something right
yeah i mean the same thing with lance
yeah
but still it's just such an incredible
lie to hold for all those years all
right
but he has one nut
right because he had statistically
cancer yeah he doesn't want that
so just imagine how small that one nut
is after using steroids for that long
that's got to be like the size of an
almond at this point
you know
somebody donated two books said are you
all going to watch the nilk pod this
week you were aware of it we even had a
write-up about it but youtube removed it
it it's gone
that was awesome so no i don't think
trump was on the knock boys yeah and
youtube [ __ ] uh sniped it because
they were talking about how trump was
still president you believe these elk
boys were talking about uh
it wasn't
you want to rip a dart with me it was
mostly him he just pays for our [ __ ]
trump got it banned
i mean i'm sure they agreed or whatever
but yeah i mean uh the the podcast was
just trump doing his verbal diarrhea for
like an hour and yeah he was just
rambling about everything and anything
it's kind of funny that he comes on your
show and it's this big thing but it's
not really because he doesn't let you
ask or engage in any interesting
conversation it's just him doing what
everyone's seen him do a thousand times
yeah trump said in the interview that
it's gonna be taken down he predicted it
would be taken down he's like that's
listen boys i love you but this is gonna
be taken down that's why i'm making you
come to me and mar-a-lago i don't put
too much effort into these
trump the the greatest thing to come
from that episode was trump said the
most amazing sound bite
and it is this hold on i'm coming
oh
dejected about it yeah not very
enthusiastic
coming coming
hold on i'm coming hold on it's like
hold on
i'm coming
anyway tom brady is uh back so uh if you
care
some guys get it all man he is so
handsome
you like everybody knows he's like super
handsome right he's the goat man like
he's so [ __ ] handsome he's like the
greatest athlete ever
i mean some guys get all of it and it's
just not [ __ ] fair and it makes me
want to shoot up a
high school i'm sorry i shouldn't go
there i'm on me dan you missed the
and it just makes me want to go to a
high school
nobody will ever love me
thank you dan you got it
um he does he has a lot
but
on the other hand he does make out with
his son so
i'm starting to think that kissing your
family members on the lips is the secret
to success oh you think he that's how he
draws let him then oh wait a minute
oh maybe he is maybe he's sucking the
life force from his son get that off the
screen it's maintained
yes this bothers you don't uh it's not
kosher i don't want to see it seriously
like [ __ ] all right i'm trying to
find how to close no i'm serious get it
out i feel bad for his son okay hold on
there we
i feel bad for his son i don't know but
like
i'm sure he loves him and stuff but that
video is so weird he goes yo come back
here what was it just a peck it's like
what do you want to make out with you
yes
he says wait hold on it was just a pack
i need more
what's more than a peck tom brady
what's more than a pack somebody tell me
it's making out you can't
get the the children's life force with
just a peck he sucks when he kisses his
phone
feed me it's like from a hocus pocus
it's like a fatality uh shao kahn is his
name huh what's his name for mortal
kombat oh chuck yeah something like that
yeah yeah i mean well gary vee's the one
initiated they're making out with his
dad so
and he's a vibrant he oh wait no it'll
be the other way around hey do you think
his dad has a v friend
of course he doesn't need one i wonder
if his dad doesn't have a v friend he's
like dad you can't come
this i would put on a shirt
family family family family
family family family family family man
that's wrong family family is wrong stop
stop uh
imagine kissing your dad like that i
can't no
my god my dad's mustache i'm gonna get
[ __ ] close to him
[Laughter]
i stick my ass out when i hug my dad
wait hold on i've never hurt my dad
never hugged her dad i'm kidding look
what the [ __ ]
that's funny
no
why'd you pull up a picture of my dad
smash that like button
okay thank you
i can remove that now
[Applause]
yeah it's weird as tom brady got way
more handsome too like
if you look at his first picture
and his um
why they got him up here like there's
like a slave trade
what is the nfl
but it looks like he's like they're
auctioning them off like what the [ __ ]
is this shot
quarterback
like
bro he looks like people like me dude
what they treat these people like me
look at this shot this looks like uh
human trafficking yeah
yeah you're wrong stand in the square
take off your shirt
put your arms down at your side
what the hell dude
humiliating
what the [ __ ]
but can you pull up the photo of him
with the
first year versus last year yeah how do
you get so much more handsome somebody
tell me
how does this work
because he looks like a dork here
right straight dork it's from all the
souls he's absorbed
with his vanquished foes like this is
like i like he's fine looking
but he's he's not like
handsome as [ __ ] here
then all of a sudden i don't know what
happens
probably got plastic surgery
do you think so like where
then look at this it all happens for him
right here
yeah the super bowl rings that gave him
life
i'm so distracted by his v-neck line
watching that transition was distracting
me the whole time wait so if he got
plastic surgery then what did he get
because his features look the same
maybe saying that he looks way more
handsome how can you say that he looks
the same his features definitely evolve
but like what surgery did he get i'm
wondering i mean
his nose maybe
his nose for sure
the nose looks a little different it
worked man
oh yeah you could see his nose like
stretching that one
yo but
it that [ __ ] works
i'm about to get some plastic surgery i
mean you can you can afford it you live
in
the capital the world capital do you
think i should no
i'm just saying you could
certainly but usually when you get
plastic surgery i always thought like it
doesn't really work
the thing is sometimes
here's the thing with plastic surgery is
that when it when it's sick when it's
like high quality and successful you
don't notice
yeah that's i guess so and it's and if
you make tom brady money you can go to
the best plastic surgeon in the world
the thing is like you know in south
korea if plastic surgery is very normal
there
and a lot of the like famous people
there supermodels whatever have like mad
plastic surgery i mean same here and the
before probably right more so here
hollywood's like no it's normalized
there it's like kids have braces here
dude they do surgery
there's [ __ ] high school students
that get it here in los angeles this is
[ __ ] crazy
i knew a girl that got plastic surgery
when she was like was it
high school graduation i mean in my
opinion it's insane to do when you're 18
and already
youthful like
but i don't know she
she wanted it for
her uh graduation gift from her family
they have money you think it's just
online there's some girl that i worked
with at a
uh restaurant yeah my this is my theory
i kind of just think it's like a
different
angle
lens that's what i kind of saw in that
picture i mean the lens can definitely
affect
what because my face shape looks like a
lot but
i think that there's long been rumors
about him having plastic surgery so
that's not just like a lens change just
in my head that's what i imagined well
can we find different photos of him
because we're not
this is so weird
uh
it's the weirdest when his gums turn
into teeth or lips or whatever yeah
that's a little frightening
okay
there you have it
this guy this is hot dude he looks like
such a goon here and i hear he looks
normal
[Music]
cause i'm seeing some pictures of this
dude i haven't seen him before but
i don't know he looks weird on some of
these pictures like now now too
yo what is this photo they really treat
these guys like cattle
does do they tag his ear and [ __ ]
probably they chip them
damn
there you have it tom brady's back guys
i don't watch football at all but he's
apparently very good
all i know about him is that he makes
out with his son
you know how this truck you know this
chocolates dog [ __ ] is because
you're not eating any of it
i have not reached for it i don't want
it
it's not good yeah now those swedish
candies i couldn't keep them out of my
mouth
that's the real test
okay tom brady's back good good good
everyone's happy
um
we
we've been going for a while yeah i'm
for two hours and 11 minutes and i know
you are not feeling well so you could
wrap it up at any time
there's so much here there's so much
they got the elon the dubrick
my throat is starting to hurt
yeah i don't think you should push it or
we're gonna end up having only this one
episode
yeah i want to be able to do it go on
friday you're right i do i'm sorry
let's we we got plenty to talk is there
any of this stuff that's time sensitive
i mean the dobrik stuff i think honestly
would benefit from us waiting a couple
days because it there aren't many people
that have seen it yet we were trying to
find like people reacting to it and i
mean def noodles
watched it and has his opinion out there
philly d uh called him a scumbag
sociopath that was actually
yeah phillyd who did not hold back
really after watching it yeah he opened
a late show saying
jesus david is a scumbag sociopath so
wait where can we can anybody watch you
can get a ticket to watch it on south by
southwest so it's still available uh
well you were able to this weekend
i don't know if it's still philly d was
there in person i believe oh what an
honor i didn't get that invite
no he just goes i mean you could go
i don't think he'd be mad to say i i've
seen the documentary
he sent me a screener
which was very kind of him he wanted to
know
casey had a case he wanted to tap my
knowledge with this
he wanted to ask me something ab you're
idle
you want to know what he wanted to ask
me
i said i don't have been this one being
my idol but yeah go ahead because most
people you say miles not my idol but i
can donate casey
you you're talking about me
yes your mind will proceed but you said
most people who say is your idol is not
you no you say
that all these people are my idol when
they're not am i your idol baby
i [ __ ] better you're my
[ __ ] especially if you take me to vegas
and be my sugar daddy for the weekend i
didn't say i was taken you know
all right anyways you were saying i said
i'd go with you that's a big difference
okay
what'd you have in mind lina are you
okay if abe puts out if i take him
jesus
he's gonna make out with you like tom
brady makes out with his son oh i'm
going straight i'm skipping the making
out
i'm sorry interrupted you're saying
casey my idol
yes what did he ask you just so you know
your your faith in me is not misplaced
he came to me for advice
that's like
like of all the people you look up it to
in the world who you idolize
they converged on me
i only found out because we asked you
for a restaurant recommendation
just saying
anyway he says he calls me he goes ethan
i'm putting out this documentary
i've been friends with david now the
whole crew hates me
and i'm really tall and i'm just really
torn up about it
he says how do you how are you so okay
with people hating you
that was this question to me i mean
i did you up for that question
what i'd hit you up for that question
too yeah i think bro
what do you want from me dude i don't
know
oh basically he was saying how is it how
are you okay being such a psychopath
that you don't care that everyone hates
you
so casey casey comes to me for the most
important life advice
that's what i said i'll say like i said
there's someone in my gym who knew where
i worked and he's like oh isn't that guy
i've heard he's like an [ __ ] in real
life and i said no he's really kind he
just gets a bad rep because he's the
only person that has the balls to call
out the [ __ ] on youtube oh thank you
who would say on my [ __ ] in real life
some guy that beat the [ __ ] out of me
the only person
oh really you scared of him yeah but
don't worry i'll adventure at i'll
avenge you i'm getting there
well don't worry because now todd we're
friends again with todd now so if we
need someone to come you mean jeff the
[ __ ] who's jeff's friend who came
together todd oh cody cody cody made
that instagram he's like hey we're good
now
we're in the family team ethan it's an
alliance he's a lion
so now that we've got cody on our team
i'll tell you what if that guy's got a
problem he can speak to cody
gabish
where'd todd come from i don't know todd
is like so far jeff's other friend from
oh there is somebody there at least okay
there's a todd
[Music]
got it
so um
i don't know the only person who's ever
said they've met me in real life when i
was an [ __ ] was anything for views
and that guy's a [ __ ] liar dude
that guy is just a huge piece of [ __ ]
for saying that
but that's the only person that's ever
said that
i get so irritated from from what that
guy said so a while ago he was friends
with keemstar he showed up to the
podcast uninvited unannounced
which i was totally fine with i was
happy to meet him
first thing he says to me when he walks
in he goes hey ethan uh
nice to meet you i talked [ __ ] about you
online
i was like okay
i didn't know that but apparently he's
been talking [ __ ] about me online
so i said okay well
welcome
he comes in we bought everyone lunch we
had a nice time we interviewed keemstar
and he left that was it and then the
next week he goes i met ethan klein in
real life he's a piece of [ __ ] i'm like
dude you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] there is
another one another person i just don't
get it man this is such a dick for no
reason
who's the other oh notch
yeah wait i gotta read this one i found
that kind of funny i knew he he should
talk to you after that interaction this
was so weird because i don't even
remember what happened
not said
actually i don't feel very comfortable
interacting with you because i'm still
bummed you told me i party too hard and
i invited you over to a party after i
invite you over to a party you are
correct by the way
okay
the only interaction we have is you keep
inviting me to your podcast i find it
kind of cringy
by the way
this tweet was him going like why
doesn't anyone invite me on their show
right yeah you were like and i said you
can come on our show
and he goes stop inviting me on your
podcast is cringy
he's a
what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dude thank
you son so i don't remember
my thoughts perfectly right there i
don't remember the interaction with
notch that much
i remember i went to his party briefly
and
i saw him
and i was eager to say hi
uh and we chatted for a bit
i don't remember anything really maybe i
am an [ __ ] because i don't even
remember saying anything to him
i i think i just said something like
i think i just wanted to hang out with
him in a more intimate setting because
like the conversation we have was like
hey let's hang out
and
i ended up at a party with like you know
hundreds of people
and he was just cruising through kind of
like a ghost ethereal nobody seemed to
give a [ __ ] about him there or even know
who he was and so
i was like let's have a smaller
get-together or something i don't know i
don't even remember
well he does
yeah
but he said i'm right so then like what
it makes no [ __ ] sense and he's
no he's definitely a weirdo he's like
tweeting his
wild [ __ ] yeah he's like i haven't
checked in on him in a while but i
remember he's just straight up
yeah he had gone pretty hard white
nationalism so
good stuff
but i just find it interesting he goes
you were correct by the way
so what was the problem
yeah
but i definitely wasn't rude to him i
remember being happy to see him and
you
know the that was it what's not you've
been tweeting you finally you looking
into it
lately let's see
between about daylight savings
but uh yeah between i guess notch and
anything for views
are two people that say i'm an [ __ ]
in real life
so there you go
i think i'm nice i don't know i try to
be a nice person and you know
[Music]
i don't
know i don't think i'm an [ __ ] to
anyone
i think you're very nice
very giving very caring
and not just you know there's people who
have money who are just giving with
their money but you are with other
things as well when i got locked out of
my apartment when i first moved here you
and eeler were the first ones to offer
to come give us a ride when cam and love
got brutally kicked out of their airbnb
i got involved randomly you guys for
them to stay at the pool house like what
just the list goes on and on
you could stay in my pool house
not in the main house right
but i i would be very happy
in my apartment it's a nice pool house
i'm just kidding i'm trying to make
myself sound like an [ __ ] but thank
you
thank you
um what's knox been up to you find
anything good dan honestly no he's just
just psychobabble
not even he's just talking about nerd
video games he's just talking about
saving daylight i don't know i think
maybe he uh
he got wise he got wise to the fact that
uh people oh i remember the conversation
so weird
was saying something like
i was like how are you doing and he was
like
good man i woke up this morning
in my pool
and there was like girls there in their
underwear and i was too shy to talk to
them he's telling me all this i said
maybe you've got to chill a little bit
on all the drugs and [ __ ]
because i
it's like why are you telling me all
this you is this a are you is this a
shout for help or something are you
looking for like
okay is this a cry for help
like the first time you meet someone and
they go i woke up in my pool and i
didn't remember where i was and there
was girls in their underwear and i was
too shy to ask them
to reach out to them i was like bro you
need to [ __ ] like stop what you're
doing
i mean yeah i don't know how many other
responses you could have to that i'd be
like okay maybe he was expecting you to
be like
whoa dude your life is so sick bro
you're so [ __ ] cool wow you made
minecraft bro that's [ __ ] awesome it
seemed to me like a legitimate cry for
help so i was like maybe not you know
like it was
like maybe stop the you know yeah i was
diagnosed as delusional so i came home
and went to bed
notch was flexing says so many checks
yeah i think so
you brought it back to real town for him
it's not flexing if he's like well to a
[ __ ] incel weirdo neckbeard dude like
who probably has never slept with a
woman like all of a sudden having all
this money and like whoa it was so crazy
i woke up with a bunch of naked girls i
don't even know what to do it's not
flexing when you're like i didn't know
what to do yeah exactly but in his like
it's all relative right so from his
framework it's like whoa this is the
craziest night i've ever had and you're
like uh maybe take it down a notch
yeah the problem the problem with nosh
is that
and he like confirms his own biases
about like all the insulin stuff about
money and stuff is because he is so
socially awkward
and he doesn't take care of himself
physically so like i think when you hate
yourself that much and you know you're
like irredeemable as a partner then you
see these women hanging out with you you
know they're just there because you're
rich
and then it confirms your own and silly
bias and then you just hate women more
it was weird pretty crazy he's a he's a
weird guy man
makes
sense does it make sense what i said
though you said dan
no i no it didn't make sense i said make
sense okay good so i was on something
yeah yeah thank you you're welcome
it doesn't make sense
um
david dobrik toured his house in a vlog
last month he did not just house
nacho's house
is that right cam
he did what the [ __ ]
weird wait was notch there cameron no
yes
has the most expensive house in l.a
what's up guys welcome back to the vlog
today i am going to and it's like by the
way a really weird house like it has
this really beautiful view obviously and
you know
some of it like i would say
some of it is really nice but 90 of it
is just unlivable weird space
like part of it is a candy store
like vats of candy
and then the other part of it is like
a weird
uh
faux museum
with like an old mustang
and
[ __ ] you just don't care about
right there's probably his livable space
where he spends time in is probably the
same as one of your guys's apartments
right the actual like where he spends 99
of his time yeah
i mean how much
room does he need he sits on a computer
all day
getting mad on twitter
dubrick
dubrick let me see this i'm meeting up
with my buddy dj he's a professional
scooter and today i'm gonna have him
jump a cliff
super dangerous let's see if he dies
[Music]
this is the dream home it's the world's
most expensive modern mansion in the
united states it's the world's most
expensive
mansion in the united states wait that's
not natural size right that's 1000
that is the one yeah oh this is the one
they just sold for 120 million exactly
dude you know who bought it the fashion
nova yep guy he's [ __ ] like i tell
you what that cheap [ __ ] clothing
pays a lot of money because the fashion
nova owner bought this house for 120
million they were very smart with their
marketing when they were coming up like
whatever deal they got worked out with
influencers like no i agree i mean that
guy figured it out yeah well what's more
what's really impressive is his design
and distribution network yeah the guy
makes [ __ ]
i mean nobody cares about the quality so
it kind of gives you a lot of freedom in
terms of just mass producing stuff
but yeah that thing all thanks to our
friends at sea geek seeking is an
amazing app that helps you buy tickets i
heard sikki came back to him is that
true yeah i mean this video was no this
is old no it's from a month ago it is
bro folks
they haven't sponsored us in a long time
maybe they'll come back i'm not working
with c geek yeah [ __ ] himself
you're [ __ ] with me
dude
yeah seeking bought him a car you didn't
do [ __ ] in fact you got paid to buy him
a car
that's the whole stick
there he is look at that freeze frame
what freeze frame no i'm david
the tongue out
but
but the documentary so yeah i watched it
is the consensus that it makes him look
really bad is that what you're reading
yeah it seemed like a lot of people
reporting that he had no remorse
none yeah there's one really interesting
part in the documentary
which i haven't seen people write up
but
he said of the girl that was essayed by
dom
he said if it happened allegedly
we don't even know if it happened or not
and he said that
after his apology video where he's like
i 100 believe the girl
so in his apology videos i 100 believe
the girl and then when casey neistat's
interviewing him and this is after that
she says
if it happened
is it is it in this quote hereby
uh
this is talking about the insider
article it's not exactly what you're
talking about but he's saying that the
article is written for clicks
nystat asked him if the insider article
was fair he said no the article was
written because they wanted clicks
he said well i love this the context he
says while sitting in a 13 million
dollar house financed by near-death
stunts
a podcast named views and a line of
clickbait merch
he seems to see the woman's account of
our word as a pesky rumor more harmful
to him than to her
i don't want to respond to it because i
don't want to feed the fire of gossip
and hate and drama i've always wanted to
be a person that when you see me you're
just like laughing or smiling or you're
pumped to have me around and now i'm
staying forever with something that i
don't necessarily think i should be
stained with
nice delusional
i look he's kind of like he's like i
just want everyone smiling and happy and
around me and but then like people who
are watching are having fun but the
people around him actually are [ __ ]
being r-worded they're being almost
killed like he
dude the dude is really sick
it's crazy
yeah his assistant natalie
is now being dubbed um
natalie uh maxwell
aptly i think
and you know they do look similar yeah i
agree
definitely looking similar
natalie maxwell
i mean user reports it's targeted
harassment at someone else [ __ ] off
whoever reported this
they're like yo this is a harassing map
jizz
just lane leave g lane alone 3g lane
for eg elaine maxwell
his assistant natalie calls herself
safety sally but it later shown
pressuring vlog squad member karina koff
to remove her shirt while filming a fake
party scene in a private jet even after
conf expresses her discomfort with the
idea yeah i remember that scene too
they wanted uh corinna to like flash all
the guys for a shot and she's like i
don't want to do it it makes me
uncomfortable i don't want to do it and
david and now they're like come on just
do it take off your top it'll be funny
that's crazy
um
quotes from rolling stone in one
particular stomach turning churning
scene that takes place on a private jet
delbrick directs members of the vlog
squad to engage in increasingly wild yet
largely innocuous behavior shots of
vodka being drizzled into their mouths
and remember he doesn't drink which
makes all the alcohol consumption so
much weirder
until he commands one vlog squad member
karina kampf to take off her shirt and
pretend to shell her breasts to the
others while they applaud
conf complies yet the degree to which
dobrick directs the action and the
degree to which everyone unfailingly
follows his lead is genuinely
uncomfortable to say the least
some on social media have not seen
neistat's film
who have not seen isis film have
categorized it as a redemption
documentary for dubrick which it is not
it is unsparing in its criticism of
influence her culture and the damage it
can wreak on others lives and how doberg
specifically abdicated his enormous
responsibility as a creator
and hurt many in the process the film
ends on a dejected note tracking how
david dobrik has largely rebounded
from the controversies and dodged
accountability
yeah so i mean
there's been
several reviews in mainstream press like
this rolling stone one in the in the
previous one
and
they all seem to be universally both uh
praising the film uh as a like in terms
of being a documentary uh as being well
put together and
of making david
look totally [ __ ] insane um
and so yeah i mean i i had been seeing
buzz that it's like
oh casey is friends with david he's
gonna try and like launder his image but
based off the reactions that are coming
out of this that does not seem to be the
case whatsoever it seems like it's it's
most people are walking out of it
thinking david is a lunatic
i mean this shot this is a scene from
the documentary which really
uh gives a really interesting context
everything that we know happened make up
a vlog it's like interesting things
and funny stuff and this is not funny
bro he says that without even a hint of
irony are you serious
he's like dead serious
let me break this down for you
and funny stuff and this is not funny
honestly gets hurt
that's by the way that's working right
there you know what i mean yeah like
that's that's working
by the way that's so [ __ ] dangerous
because that thing can if you go tilted
wrong he'll go head first into
yeah the ground the
can you concrete even a little bit
higher and then he's pushing him to go
more higher than he's comfortable with
do these stuns ever concern you natalie
yeah all the time that's my job that's
why i'm here i'm here to be like safety
sally okay
i'm the big i put the no have you said
no to david before oh yeah all the time
we're gonna stay here
and it's gonna be like okay watch out
watch out what's that look out you need
more power on the throw
i'm not worried about this happening i'm
worried about my reaction when it
happens because it's going to happen
he's not just blessed with his his
talents he's also blessed with this
insane luck that everything always works
out for him
oh
so ironic jeff jeff's saying so sad and
ironic that jeff was the one to deliver
that line brutal
brutal
pretty incredible actually that context
of all that
i'm not just blessed with his
yeah i mean
from the perspective
of casey you know um
stepping away from the seriousness of
the
the the the hurt and damage that
happened um
i mean he really hit the jackpot when it
comes to like a documentary
because
i mean
he went into this is making essentially
a fluff piece yeah and the fact that it
just evolved into kind of like this
close examination of this toxic
you know influencer culture is um
that's lightning in a bottle man like he
really he he lucked out well i told i
told him it was like uh
those fire fights those guys who were
making the documentary about the
firefighters on 9 11 right exactly yeah
really is
luck that everything always works out
for him
[Music]
yeah good editing choice dude
show that not working out overnight it
did they did get it right i'm sure they
did eventually but yeah
there's a lot of great moments in there
though so
pretty [ __ ] interesting
tongue out baby
this is how we do it
this is how we do it
um i'm kind of curious what philly d
said
i time stamped it that link there
i mean i pretty much summed it
he has more to say as well but uh came
out with some fighting words yup
been doing it
today i'm actually coming did this just
come out today yeah this morning okay
back from texas i was at the premiere of
under the influence at south by
southwest it's the casey neistat
documentary about david dobrik and i
just wow i cannot diagnose anyone but
watching this documentary it's hard not
to look at david dover and be like oh
you are a scumbag sociopath you've said
what you've said publicly but you behind
the scene you still truly see yourself
as the victim of your controversies
right so with this i yo by the way thank
you liam
casey has never
he has never like exposed anybody it's
so weird that this like expose on david
is coming from casey neistat of all
people yeah
like you know it's bad when casey right
i think i'd lends it a certain
legitimacy that he's not somebody
yeah again like i remember everyone he's
friends with
he's friends with everyone and this
documentary was explicitly
set out upon with the goal of
documenting
somebody that he thought was a
fascinating
positive creator and the fact that he
learned reality just completely twisted
that in another direction i think is
i think it's really fascinating
yeah i think by the end casey
hated him coming out he went in loving
him he came out hating him
not unlike how you guys come in here uh
right and my relationship with you yeah
no um i watched a uh
i watched an interview with casey this
morning as well at south by um you know
the official uh panel or whatever and um
he was very uh
cagey about talking about his
relationship with david um but he made
it pretty clear that essentially the
the final interview in the film the last
one that he did with him david has gone
completely zero contact with him ever
since then he has not spoken to him
since that interview yeah makes sense
yeah so i don't think david is thrilled
he is not this
how it turned out which is crazy to
think about i mean he spent like what
almost three years two years three two
and a half years spent two years filming
with this guy and
now he's just like i never want to see
your face again
ouch
you know
he's just
if he was more mature
there is a redemption arc for david
where he's like
i
com you know i've missed the mark with
that one
no but he's like
i
am completely blinded to
all of the risks that i've put all these
people through
i need to take away step away take a
break
i need to learn i need to look inside
[Music]
but he's refusing to
acknowledge he really truly believes
that he's done nothing wrong yeah
in both cases which when it comes to
when it comes to the dom thing
like i disagree strongly that it he is
not responsible but i can see that
there's some space for uh
self delusion to be like dom did it i
wasn't in the room but with jeff you
literally [ __ ] were in control of the
excavator
yep
yeah that one is eighty percent he goes
i can take maybe eighty percent i just
don't understand how
if if i
hurt a friend that gravely i would like
devote my entire life
to them i feel like or like making sure
that they can also lift their life too
dude especially considering he could
easily
be in jail for life
and like financially too like they were
late on payments and stuff like that he
has he can easily just make that happen
did you see were you watching when we
talked about how he only wanted to go
halves on the stem cell [ __ ] yes
that was crazy
and this is yeah i mean i don't know
what to say this is basically what i
said to him casey ethan how can you be
okay people hating you ethan you'll
learn baby you'll learn i mean i don't
know what to tell you bro it is what it
is
you just gotta have to live with it
i said i don't i just look casey if
someone i don't like if someone that i
don't respect doesn't like me what the
[ __ ] do i care
that's really it
i don't give a [ __ ] i agree
that
also but also part of the it's part of
the gig if you're gonna be calling
people out yeah people are gonna dislike
you absolutely
and if they got a problem i'll send i'll
send my boy uh
not todd yeah if there's somebody like
there's if there's somebody that you
like and respect cody cole i'm gonna
spend my boy cody
to pay you a visit there's somebody that
you like and respect that uh thinks that
you're a piece of [ __ ] it's
definitely should give you pause and
yeah time to reflect but if we're you
know and controversially
i've learned that people that you think
are a piece of [ __ ] like you that should
also give you a pause
and times in my career
those have been the most important times
that i've been given pause and said wait
i'm i need to reconsider what i'm doing
because when someone like crowder
likes you
then you need to [ __ ] reevaluate it
right exactly because that's what was
happening to me back and like we've been
talking about recently with all how all
of these people keep collecting this
this uh or uh connecting the uh
the legion of doom the h3 legion of doom
and when you list these people off it's
like okay so who like [ __ ] hates us
or you specifically more so but hate the
show just trying to hate us too but yeah
well sure ryan cavanaugh
keemstar
jstation faze banks
ricegum
wait a minute
these are these are the worst people
that you can think of it's kind of okay
that's great people hate us yeah they
should hate me yeah it's all about the
respect i'm not gonna [ __ ] suck their
dicks and lie about what i think they're
great and have them you know [ __ ] them
yeah just scum
it's all about the respect
that's right
as i spit on this dead body i found
you know so whatever
and uh
yeah
okay i don't want to do like a
play-by-play of the movie it premiered
at south by southwest i don't know if
it's been purchased yet i don't know
when it's going to be publicly
consumable what starts as something
that's meant to kind of showcase the
rise of this youtuber ends up focusing
on the essay dirty dom accusations as
well as a jeff whitakrain incident
what's really interesting is a lot of
public reaction right now is kind of
just based off of people sharing their
initial reviews of their like south by
southwest screeners and so depending on
where you're scrubbing on the internet
there are places that are like oh my god
you can tell casey neistat was never
really david dobrik's friend he was just
trying to use them in the
the david dobrik stands are so crazy
that's
crazy take
that's a 12 year old take
man
i really hope this gets huge
distribution by the way
i mean it should he's getting such good
reception i i can't imagine you know an
amazon or a uh netflix somebody's gotta
pick that up it's not gonna want it it's
already made you just buy the license
yeah well i mean that's what film
festivals like south by exist for is to
find distributors so
i'm sure
somebody's gonna pick it up yeah his
views are still crazy
that's all oh he's in post in three
weeks
but his views are so crazy
i mean hey people still listen to
michael jackson you know what i mean
i'm not looking to the side my head is
wanting to crank over so bad
hey you know what michael jackson come
on the radio
it's hard not to hit thrust your hip to
that [ __ ]
billie jean is not my love
i don't like women and she
oh really
i didn't know where it was going
billie jean is not my love first of all
she's
the wrong gender and two-world
yeah
billie jean oh my god he's my lover
he's a 12 year old boy that's just the
time i'm doing me
yesterday [ __ ] i've been waiting for
this baby you know what billie jean
isn't my lover but billy and gene love
those two boys oh my god
where come on where's the dance moves
babies dance
billy gene is billy take off your jeans
[Music]
[Laughter]
baby girl let's see it i want to see the
moves
is it that you don't is you do you don't
want to dance or you don't want to dance
to the piano trick you're somehow going
to get [ __ ] twisted come on
really dancing to this yeah
billy take off your jeans
you are the one except for the 12 other
i'm just saying
i'm just saying i'm just saying just
saying just saying i miss you
how about i do another polly walnuts
what is paulie walnuts i did a polly
walnuts impersonation when you did the
godfather last week give me a paulie
walnut all right ready
sure that's it
oh i don't speak for these okay okay
okay
okay okay
oh by the way they're definitely
deleting comments because every time i
go here
it's all just super positive
and i know between ours and jeff's
[Music]
um actually that comment yeah there's
some
they got bored and stuff wait did we
talk about the two hour thing
you know i think that was after this
okay this was a huge revelation actually
can you pull up that screenshot
from the subreddit somebody on the
subreddit did a really brilliant csi
of david's
um
episode talking about the accident
and what you'll notice if you watch or
give me a time stamp if you can
what you'll notice because david there's
this moment where he pulls up
an instagram dm
that jeff sent him
showing someone swinging from an
excavator but jeff himself admits he
didn't see it
until jeff was already in the hospital
but i guess he he thinks it's useful to
deflect blame on jeff somehow to prove
that like he wanted to do it
well what was really a self-report
is that the desktop recording
which we're looking for
shows okay good thank you baby
you're on your [ __ ] today
minutes before the app this is the
biggest self report ever
now i know my solo res that's not that
this time
it's on hd
we do need a high res for this
so
let's try this one more time
so
here he he screen recorded this on his
phone
we got to go back a little bit
and i remember i remember jeff told me
check my dms
and it was it was a video that he found
okay
now he's this says two hours ago that
means he screen recorded it two hours
after jeff sent it
now the timeline is this
jeff
sent this message when he was on the
beach
and people were on the excavator
soon after the the accident happened and
he was rushed to the hospital so
according to the timeline
only one person was allowed in to be
with jeff during the surgery and david
was that person
so while
jeff was on the operating table and
people didn't know if he was going to
live or die
while everybody was outside just cr
praying that he survives david was in
there
screen recording
the dm
to try to uh
to try to [ __ ]
put the blame on jeff
in case uh he got sued or jeff died
there's no other way to interpret that
the only other way because we were
discussing who are ours his friends
might be down oh i agree i agree the
only
because we were
trying to think of like some sort of
explanation for why somebody would do
that other than what you just described
which
is the most likely uh interpretation
however
maybe
you know they i'm sure the the whole
vlog squad and their production team has
a group chat and was probably going
insane during this whole like process or
whatever and maybe he was just trying to
explain the the series of events that
how would he say why would he need to
desktop record it why not just send a
screenshot because maybe he was still
thinking he was going to be making a
video
about this why is he even think i don't
know bro i i don't see that as plausible
but i and the thing is he used it as he
intended right the fact that he rolled
it out like this years later yeah which
is kind of crazy that he still had that
that's by the way he also did that with
the dom thing he had like the receipts
and all that [ __ ]
or seth
so like he has a history of having like
receipts to defend himself yeah if clerk
comes out he's always trying to think of
the angle that could get him in trouble
and trying to cover his ass well he
knows he's like this could [ __ ] me up
and so he was trying to prepare for it
and so he's using this video he took two
hours after jeff sent it he's in the
hospital he might die he's using it
exactly as he intended that's why i'm so
sure that that's what the purpose of
this video was like 15 minutes before
the accident that somebody posted
and he said let's recreate this and it
was a guy
swinging from an excavator and flying
off i didn't see that dm until the
hospital and he jokes he's like i didn't
mean literally dude he used that exactly
how he intended
and he's really dumb because it doesn't
do anything to help him
uh if but i think he's just desperate
because he knows he's [ __ ]
but just imagine dude
you're like man this guy could die and i
did it well hold on let me download this
real fast in case he tries to sue me or
somebody said that's a screenshot not
recording the recording indicating the
top left is for the podcast they were
recording no look at it again yeah
carefully that's a whole oh
it's a whole video an iphone recording
yeah navigate when you're in the
hospital with something like that
because you don't know whether or not to
be like because he clicks on the post
itself
and it plays and the po the post itself
says that you know how to do it posted
two hours ago if you're doubting it
watch this
and i remember i remember how are these
guys letting david do it like jason
seems like
he cares about jeff as a friend and
stuff
how is he sitting there natalie's a
[ __ ] she's just lame so i'm not
surprised about anything about her
but how is jason going to let him sit
there and show that video and try to
blame jeff it just seems so spineless
remember jeff told me check my dms
and it was it was a video that he found
okay so
here's the desktop recording icon it
says sent two hours ago
okay
like 50 he clicks the message before the
accident that he clicks the video
videos
this is a screen shot a guy
no i'm saying like the people that are
doing that
yeah that's not a screenshot and he
jokes he's like i didn't mean literally
that was definitely interacting with the
post itself and that 50 cent post itself
also says posted two hours ago so
yeah no this this video was recorded two
hours after the accident i mean it's
just such a self-own such a self-report
it's really
damning evidence really gross behavior i
mean that's an understatement my
goodness
yeah i'll never but the best moment of
this comes when when jason says i think
jeff will be really happy about this
fantastic
um i think i think jeff's
response was like word for word that's
that's not jason that's not jason i
don't know who i'm looking at yeah
yeah i mean that was a hell of a
statement because even david and ellie
were like what
yeah i don't know man
but at the end of the day i don't think
anything's gonna stop david
right i mean you still make videos and
seeking still working with them for
christ's sake
i mean if he doesn't course correct
uh
i
can't see
something else like this
not happening in the future you know
what i mean which
well he seeing as he doesn't seem to
really get it i i don't know if he is
going to course correct yeah but it
happened and nothing happened to him so
what is what does he have to gain he
still he lost a lot in this even if he's
but now he has nothing left to lose
yeah
i suppose i feel like when this casey
dock is more publicly available it'd be
a good test because it doesn't get any
cleaner than casey on youtube so
yeah for sure
but yeah i mean these views are great
it's going to be really interesting to
see how this goes down man
dave and natalie are just so pit they're
all out to get us
i didn't do anything
i'm only 80 responsible for the
excavator accident
yo apparently
alec baldwin is like
i haven't been following closely but
apparently he's like
kind of in some hot water with the dust
shooting thing
rust rust yeah
i like dust better
i i uh i don't know i think he said like
a quote similar to david like it's not
fun unless someone gets hurt or
something
no kidding
not fun unless someone's shot
i don't know
i've been seeing tweets about how he's
like actually being investigated and he
said some really bad things and
interviews and
apparently he's
not doing a good job with
uh
navigating he
i like baldwin
i'm seeing that he's in legal trouble
for some thing with the january sixth
insurrection i don't know but i got some
dm's doesn't seem related
yeah regarding the strip club it was
definitely sam's idea
somebody exposed you i was olivia
sam wants to go to the strip club dude
abs dirty 30.
ianna what do you think about sam
wanting to go to the strip club
hey you know i mean i'm just gonna be
supportive if that's what she wants us
to do you know what are you just gonna
see him i'm gonna stand by her decision
and um i'll be there for her sounds fun
yeah
sounds like a good time
wait wait a b or love you said you want
to go to the strip club here
he said i want to get juiced up
which is not good in that in that
yeah
like that you guys are misunderstanding
the juice dudes i wanted like why it's
juiced not juiced
oh you said let's go to vegas you want
to get the snail trail as our caller
said so we meant by no no no no no okay
just no
you know you don't want the snail trail
to be clear some people do
what about you sec
i've
i asked you man
yeah the answer is no all right sam and
i will be going let me know if any of
these guys are just afraid of getting
canceled they were all down to go
literally why are you getting cancer for
going to a strip club i don't know why
they they're well i'm just afraid
sometimes people gotta keep it real no i
i wasn't different i literally tagged
lena in the chat i was like you down
that's true
exactly lena's the only real one here
yeah for the most ganks out of all of us
for sure she's like yeah i'll go
all nice and chipper yeah
you guys are just misunderstanding what
we're saying i said i'm going there
going you said you want to get juiced up
yeah bro i think you're like one of us
cup of drinks a cup of drinks yeah a
couple drinks you know
that's all yeah hey and now that
everything's on the water all the
comments of uh i mean on the open leave
love alone
boy i want to get juiced up what can i
say this boy i'm looking to get juice up
that's all
it's just boys we're gonna get juiced i
mean he's on vacation he's on vacation
[ __ ] america he wants to get used up
there's nothing wrong with that anyway i
gotta ask hilo if uh
if we can go but yeah that'd be fun this
week on our next weekend vegas
people las vegas baby
yeah
make sure they behave
nice
what's the most trouble we can get to in
vegas just
losing too much money at the table tell
someone
what you could kill someone i could kill
someone
yeah you asked what's the most trouble
yeah you run someone over on the vegas
strip arrest your rolls-royce
trouble yeah that'd be trouble yeah
that'd be a lot of trouble
anyone else
uh i could hijack the plan dan get the
button ready
no no i'm i'm i don't know
i don't know if i trust how well this
mute works yeah read it it's something
bigger together
let me put it this way oh god there's a
hotel
right no
dude i already get stopped at the
airport there's a hotel called new york
you guys know that new york
[Laughter]
all right enough enough
just saying there could be always
something worse all right let's wrap it
up i want to be able to do a show on
friday
thanks for watching guys wednesday what
about wednesday oh it's monday right
it's monday my dude oh like
wednesday
you thought it was wednesday because
we're off the rails today
probably
right yeah people saying he can still
hear you because you're getting picked
up on the other mics so oh really yeah
okay well listen
god damn it thanks for watching we'll
see you
on wednesday all right you take care you
be good okay take care of your mother
tell her i said hi
give her a kiss for me gabish around the
lips tom brady style
[Music]
you